ALL RIGHT. THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER. WELCOME AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT. LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. FOR PURPOSES
OF ESTABLISHING A QUORUM,
SENATOR PADILLA PRESENT. SENATOR
NEAL, I WOW. I LIKE THAT. KEEP
DOING THAT, SENATOR. KEEP DOING
THAT. SENATOR SMALLWOOD, WE'RE
HERE, MR. CHAIR, YOU HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FIRST, A NOTE. I'LL TAKE A
MOMENT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE,
COLLEAGUES, IF I MIGHT, DO
SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT ATYPICAL,
BUT PROBABLY SHOULD BE DONE MORE
OFTEN, ALYSSA NGUYEN, TIMOTHY
GRIFFITHS AND DIEGO LOPEZ ARE
OUTSTANDING PROFESSIONAL BUDGET
STAFFERS AND THEY DON'T OFTEN
GET THE RECOGNITION THAT THEY
DESERVE FOR THE HARD WORK THAT
THEY DO. AND WE WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO CONDUCT THE STATE'S
BUSINESS ON THESE IMPORTANT
MATTERS IF THEY DID NOT HAVE
THEM AND THEIR TALENT, I WANT TO
ISSUE ALSO HERE AN APOLOGY. IT'S
A LITTLE EMBARRASSING, BUT I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT I
MENTION IT. I RARELY ASK
ANYTHING OF STAFF ON A WEEKEND,
AND BECAUSE OF NOT FEELING SO
GREAT, YOU MIGHT REMEMBER LAST
YEAR I COULD HARDLY SPEAK, I
ASKED IF WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE A
BRIEFING OVER THE WEEKEND
BECAUSE OF AN INTERNAL
MISCOMMUNICATION IN MY OFFICE.
YOURS TRULY WAS NOT PRESENT AT
THAT BRIEFING, AND THIS WAS A
TIME THAT SOME OF OUR FINE STAFF
HAD MOVED THEIR PERSONAL
SCHEDULES AROUND TO ACCOMMODATE
ME. SO I WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO
YOU ALL FOR THAT. AND I WANT TO
JUST ASK THIS AUDIENCE TO MAYBE
HELP ME SHOW THEM SOME
RECOGNITION FOR THEIR WORK. WE
COULDN'T DO IT WITHOUT HIM. SO I
APPRECIATE THEM VERY MUCH. AND
WITH THAT, WE WILL GET DOWN TO
WORK. AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
DOCKET, ISSUES ONE THROUGH EIGHT
WILL BE LATER FOR VOTE. VOTE
ONLY ITEMS. ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION
BEGINNING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. GO-BIZ WILL BE
ISSUES TAKEN ONE AT A TIME.
ISSUES NINE THROUGH 14. SO
PLEASE COME FORWARD ALONG WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ALLEGE. I GUESS
WE'RE CRAMMING EVERYONE AT THE
SAME TABLE THESE DAYS. SO I'M
TOLD, SO MAKE YOURSELVES
COMFORTABLE. AND, OF COURSE, AS
ALWAYS, STATE YOUR NAME AND
TITLE FOR THE RECORD AND PROCEED
WHEN READY. WELCOME THANK YOU,
CHAIR. PADILLA COLBY. WHITE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO, THE
FIRST ISSUE BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
THE CAL COMPETES GRANT PROGRAM,
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED,
50,000,000 IN 1 TIME FUNDING,
PLUS 10 MILLION CARRIED OVER
FROM THE PRIOR YEAR FOR FISCAL
YEAR 24 FIVE ON A ONE TIME
BASIS, THIS FOLLOWS THREE FISCAL
YEARS WHERE THE PROGRAM HAS
RECEIVED 120,000,000 IN 1 TIME
FUNDING EACH YEAR, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO, WITHDRAW
THAT 50 MILLION IN FUNDING,
INCLUDING THE 10 MILLION THAT'S
CARRIED OVER FROM THE PRIOR
YEAR. AND TO REVERT THAT 10
MILLION TO THE GENERAL FUND.
THANK YOU. I'LL HAVE COMMENT.
BÀN. EULALIO, THIS THIS, ACTION
IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR EARLIER
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS ITEM. SO
WE RECOMMEND APPROVING. ALL
RIGHT. I'LL BRING IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. SENATOR NEAL.
THANK YOU. CHAIR HAS THERE BEEN
ANY OUTREACH TO LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THE ONE HERE, THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO ECONOMIC COUNCIL, TO
FIND OUT HOW EFFECTIVE THESE TAX
CREDITS ARE? THESE LOCAL
ENTITIES ARE, LARGELY DEALING
WITH OUT OF STATE COMPANIES TO
LOCATE LOCALLY HERE AND WOULD
HAVE A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS AS A TOOL FOR
THEIR EFFORTS. SURE. LAUREN
GREENWOOD, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATION FOR GO-BIZ, YES. OUR
OUR CAL COMPETES UNIT, AS WELL
AS OUR CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
INVESTMENT SERVICES UNIT,
INTERFACES VERY FREQUENTLY WITH
BUSINESSES AND TRADE
ORGANIZATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
THIS THEY'RE PUTTING FORWARD THE
MOST ATTRACTIVE RESOURCES AND
INCENTIVES TO ATTRACT THOSE
BUSINESSES TO, TO LOCATE IN, IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WE DEFINITELY CAN
CONTINUE THAT OUTREACH. HAPPY TO
TAKE FEEDBACK ON OTHER WAYS THAT
WE CAN WORK WITH THESE
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STATE IS PACKAGING THE MOST
ATTRACTIVE RESOURCES AS WE CAN
DO. THEY GENERALLY RELATE THESE
PROGRAMS AS HELPFUL TO THEIR
EFFORTS, YES, I WOULD SAY SO.
THANK YOU. I SENT A QUESTION IN
TERMS OF, WITH THESE, STATE
TRADE EXPANSION PROGRAM STEP,
HOW MUCH IS FOCUSED ON
ATTRACTING, AND GROWING GREEN
SECTOR INDUSTRY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA? CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT HOW OUR CLIMATE,
GOALS ARE PRIORITIZED THROUGH
THESE FEDERAL DOLLARS? LAUREN
GREENWOOD, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATION, YOU KNOW, I, I
BELIEVE THAT MIGHT BE WITH OUR
INTERNATIONAL UNIT, AND SO I
DON'T HAVE THE DETAILS ON
EXACTLY WHICH SECTORS ARE
TARGETING, SO I'D BE HAPPY TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT. JUST TO
REITERATE SOME EARLIER SORT OF
THOUGHTS, I MEAN, AS WE LOOK AT
INCREDIBLY CONSTRAINED
SCENARIOS, THERE ARE OFTEN NO
GOOD CHOICES. BUT HERE I'VE
SPOKEN BEFORE, MY PERSONAL
PHILOSOPHY THAT WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT PROTECTING
STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS AND THE
TYPES OF EXPENDITURES THAT I
WOULD CHARACTERIZE AS STRATEGIC,
AS THEY HAVE SOME REASONABLE
PROBABILITY OF BEING ABLE TO
LEVERAGE LONG TERM RETURN, ON
CRITICAL THINGS LIKE DEVELOPING
EVOLVING INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
RIPE FOR ATTRACTION OF
INVESTMENT AND NEW JOBS, THINGS
THAT ARE LINKED OR DIRECTLY
RELEVANT TO CRITICAL EMERGING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE. FOR
EXAMPLE, LIKE LITHIUM VALLEY.
AND I KNOW THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
DISTRICT ONLY CONCERN. I'VE
ARGUED HERE MANY TIMES IN OTHER
PLACES, THIS IS A STATEWIDE
ISSUE, THAT HAS SOME TREMENDOUS
RETURN ON INVESTMENT CAPACITY
AND A CAPABILITY HERE. SO I
ALWAYS, I ALWAYS THINK ABOUT
WHEN WE ARE BEING CONSTRAINED,
ARE WE ALSO BEING STRATEGIC. AND
I'M NOT SO SURE THAT THIS IS
THAT MOVE, I WANTED TO MAKE THAT
KNOWN AS WELL. SO IF THERE ARE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
COMMENT I THANK YOU. THIS ITEM
WILL BE HELD. WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM
TEN, WHICH IS TO REDUCE THE
PROPOSAL TO RECAPITALIZE
INFRASTRUCTURE, STATE REVOLVING
FUND AND SEE IF WE HAVE NEW
PRESENTERS ON THAT. AGAIN,
WELCOME AND PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. OKAY. HI. CHARLES SAU,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS, THAT'S
WHAT THIS FIRST ONE IS HERE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED $50
MILLION. ONE TIME FOR THE
GENERAL FUND TO RECAPITALIZE
THIS FUND TO SUPPORT LOW
INTEREST FINANCING LOANS,
SPECIFICALLY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. THIS
SOLUTION REDUCES THIS INVESTMENT
BY 20 MILLION. TO MAINTAIN THE
FUND SOLVENCY AND CONTINUE
OFFERING LOW INTEREST LOANS FOR
2425. AM I ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
THE SRF RIGHT NOW? THE
VERIFICATION PROCESS, SORRY,
NOTWITHSTANDING POTENTIAL MERITS
OF AN ALLOCATION IN THIS AREA,
OUR POSITION CONTINUES TO BE
THAT YOU SHOULD REJECT THE
FUNDING ENTIRELY. THANK YOU.
MOVING TO THE SOUTH. ALL RIGHT.
THAT'LL BE HELPFUL. THANK YOU.
ISSUE 11, INTRODUCTION TO THE
SMALL BUSINESS ASSISTANCE. OKAY.
YEAH CHARLES SAU, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE 2022 BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED $6 MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN 2223 TO BOLSTER THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EXPANSION PROGRAM AND
SUPPORT INCREASED DEMAND. AND
THEN THAT ALSO INCLUDED 23
MILLION ANNUALLY THEREAFTER, TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO UNDERSERVED
BUSINESS GROUPS AND BUSINESSES
IN LOW WEALTH, RURAL AND
DISASTER IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
THIS SOLUTION REDUCES THE
PROGRAM TO $10 MILLION FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS, AND THEN
RESTORES IT TO $23 MILLION IN
2627, AND THEN ONGOING. DELYLAH
WE WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT
SINCE THE ALLOCATION OF THE
ADDITIONAL 6 MILLION PER YEAR
WAS MADE IN THE 2022 BUDGET ACT,
THE STATE HAS RECEIVED, 25
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS TO
PROVIDE A SIMILAR, ALTHOUGH NOT
ENTIRELY, THE SAME, TYPE OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND OBTAINING LOANS,
SO THAT AMOUNT IS ROUGHLY,
ROUGHLY ABOUT THE SAME AS THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT IS BEING
PROPOSED TO BE CUT UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL. ALL RIGHT. SO THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THE PROGRAM IS
TO FOCUS ON UNDERSERVED SMALL
BUSINESSES TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE
EQUITY WHEN IT COMES TO ACCESS.
HOW DOES THIS ALIGN WITH THAT?
SURE, WE ARE FORTUNATE. LAUREN
GREENWOOD, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATION FOR GO-BIZ, WE ARE
FORTUNATE THAT, CAL THE OFFICE
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE
DOES IS RECEIVING FEDERAL
DOLLARS AT $25.3 MILLION OVER
FIVE YEARS, WE AND THAT IS ALSO
FOCUSED ON, SUPPORTING CAPITAL
READINESS FOR SOCIALLY
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
INDIVIDUALS, VERY SMALL
BUSINESSES AND SMALL MICRO
ENTERPRISES, SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO THERE IS SOME OVERLAP OF THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FUND. SO
WE'D BE HOPEFUL THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES WOULD STILL BE
ASSISTED, ALTHOUGH NOT AS
GREATLY AS WITH THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM CURRENTLY,
THE CHARLES SAU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALSO ADD THAT
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS, WHICH IS THE ONE OF THE
MAIN REASONS WE MAINTAIN THE $10
MILLION AND THEN RESTORE IT TO
$23 MILLION IN 26, 27. ALL
RIGHT. THE SUB, SENATOR NILO. SO
PRESUMABLY THE INTENT OF THIS IS
REALLY FUNDAMENTALLY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. IMPROVE THE
COMPETENCY OF SMALL BUSINESSES,
JOB CREATION ULTIMATELY, ANY
ADDITIONAL TAX REVENUES, DO YOU
HAVE ANY DATA ON THAT SORT OF
RETURN? YES, I DON'T HAVE THAT,
AT THIS MOMENT, BUT I'M HAPPY TO
GET BACK TO YOU WITH SOME OF THE
TYPES OF BUSINESSES THAT OUR
CURRENT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM SUPPORTS. OKAY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CHÁVEZ, I JUST WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT. CAN YOU SAY A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THEN WHAT WOULD
BE THE IMPACT OF THE STATE
PULLING BACK THIS $10 MILLION
AND THEN RESTORING IT? IS THERE
A SENSE OF WHAT SUPPORT WOULD BE
DISRUPTED WITH THE GAP IN THE
FUNDING? SURE, LAUREN GREENWOOD
GÓMEZ, SO, TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IS A VERY BROAD TERM, AND IT CAN
MEAN A LOT OF THINGS. SO UNDER
THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES,
SPECIFICALLY, THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL FOCUS ON
ACCOUNTING, FINANCIAL, LEGAL,
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SERVICES.
AND THEN, HOWEVER, THE CURRENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
WITH THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS, IT'S SUPPORTS A WIDER
SCOPE OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND THAT INCLUDES PROVIDING, A
DIVERSE SUITE OF SERVICES, WHICH
ENABLES BUSINESSES TO REACH MORE
MARKETS WITHIN THE STATE AND NOT
ONLY LIMITED TO LEGAL, FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTING SERVICES. SO IT'D BE
LIKE MARKETING HELPING DEVELOP A
BUSINESS PLAN, BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT POTENTIALLY
SUPPORTING SOME, YOU KNOW, HUMAN
RESOURCES QUESTIONS, ONE ON ONE
COUNSELING AND TRAINING SUPPORT
AND ENABLING THEM TO GROW AND
SCALE AND FURTHER SUPPORT THEIR
BUSINESS PLAN. SO, THERE'S SO
UNDER THE CURRENT PROGRAM,
THERE'S A BIT MORE, LATITUDE OF
SERVICES THAT CAN BE OFFERED
JUST WITH THE FEDERAL PROGRAM.
IT IS MORE LIMITED. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE IT'S SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORTING THE $1.2 BILLION IN
FEDERAL FUNDS. WE HAVE, THAT IS
GIVEN FOR CAPITAL LOANS, SO THE
SMALL BUSINESS LOAN PROGRAM WITH
THE EYE BANK, THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE ALSO GETS SOME OF THOSE
FEDERAL DOLLARS. SO THE CURRENT
FEDERAL, DOLLARS ARE REALLY
FOCUSED ON HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND BUSINESSES ACCESS
THOSE LOAN PRODUCTS THROUGH THE,
THROUGH THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES.
I JUST NOTING HOW THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE A LOT IS CORE SERVICE
IN THAT ACCOUNTING AND LEGAL
SUPPORT. SO MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES DO RELY ON THAT. AND
THEN, THE ABILITY TO SCALE. SO
IT SEEMS LIKE THE STATE PROVIDES
A SERIES OF SUPPORTS THAT THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS DO NOT. AND THAT
WOULD LEAVE, SMALL BUSINESSES
VULNERABLE WITH THOSE FUNDS, AND
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF HOW MANY
BUSINESSES ACCESS THE, THE STATE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE PROPOSED TO
BE CUT? I, I DO, I'D HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOUR OFFICE ON THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE SUB? WE'LL MOVE TO.
THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD. WE'LL
MOVE TO ISSUE 12 ADDITIONAL
DELAYS. THE CITY OF FRESNO
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN FUNDING.
PLEASE PROCEED. ALSO SAU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE 2023
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED $250 MILLION
TO SUPPORT THE CITY OF FRESNO'S
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN. GO-BIZ HAS
ALLOCATED $50 MILLION IN 2324
THE CITY OF FRESNO, THIS
PROPOSED, DELAY PUSHES THE
FUNDING OUT TO THE FULL 200
MILLION OUT TO 2627. ALL RIGHT.
LEO NØ SCHUSTER IS ON THIS ITEM.
ALL RIGHT. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR NEIL? A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE SPENDING
IS THE HIGH SPEED RAIL STATION,
RIGHT. SOMEBODY DOESN'T LIKE
THAT, WHAT IS THE PROJECTION OF
THE TIME, BY WHICH THAT STATION
WOULD BE NEEDED? THE SORRY TO
THE QUESTION WAS, WHAT TIME WILL
THE COMPLETION WITH THE PROJECT
BE COMPLETED FOR THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL? NØ WHAT TIME WILL IT WHAT
TIME? BY WHAT TIME WILL THE
STATION BE NEEDED FOR THE
OPERATION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL,
WHICH WE'VE KNOWN BY RECENT
REPORTS BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE,
IS, SHALL WE SAY, SOMEWHAT
CHALLENGED. SO WHAT'S THE
PROJECTED TIME BY WHICH THAT
STATION WILL BE NEEDED, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT. I DON'T I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION WITH US RIGHT
NOW. I WOULD SUGGEST THEN THAT
THIS SPENDING MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT CHALLENGED IF WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHEN THE BENEFIT OF IT IS
NEEDED, BECAUSE IT IS ON A
CRITICAL LINE. IF YOU BUILD IT
NOW, IT WOULD BE SITTING THERE
AN UNUSED ASSET. SO THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION. YEAH. YES I
THINK SENATOR'S POINT IS A
FOLLOW UP. WE HAVE WE LOOKED AT
TRYING TO QUANTIFY ADDITIONAL
INCREMENTAL OR OTHER COSTS THAT
MIGHT BE INCURRED BY RESULTING
FROM THE DELAY. LAUREN GREENWOOD
WITH GO-BIZ, I THINK SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL COSTS FOR DELAY THAT
WE PREVIEWED EARLIER IN A
PREVIOUS HEARING JUST WOULD BE
TYPICAL COST OF INFLATION, YOU
KNOW, EXTENSIONS OF CONTRACTS
AND ENSURING THAT THERE IS A
WORKFORCE AVAILABLE TO DO THE,
TO PROVIDE THE CONSTRUCTION AND
SERVICES NEEDED TO COMPLETE THE
JOB. ALL RIGHT. ADDITIONAL. ALL
RIGHT. THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD
OPEN. ISSUE 13, WHICH IS A SWEEP
OF PERFORMING ARTS, EQUITABLE
PAYROLL FUND. PLEASE PROCEED.
CHARLES SAU, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE 23 THE 2023 BUDGET
ACT TRANSFER THE REMAINING
FUNDING TOTALING $12.5 MILLION
FROM TWO PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT THE
PERFORMING ARTS. EQUITABLE
PAYROLL FUND. THIS FUND WAS
ESTABLISHED PURSUANT TO SB 1116
OF 2022, AND WAS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT SMALL PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS TO HIRE AND RETAIN
EMPLOYEES. THIS IS A GENERAL
FUND SOLUTION THAT WOULD REVERT
THE 12.5 MILLION BACK TO THE
GENERAL FUND. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU ALL. NÓ COMMENT TO THE SUB.
IF NONE, THEN I WILL HOLD THAT
ITEM OPEN. WE'LL MOVE TO 14,
WHICH IS THE SAVINGS FROM SMALL
AGRICULTURAL BUSINESS DROUGHT
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM. OH, I'M
SORRY, SENATOR SMALLWOOD. NO, NO
WORRIES. THANK YOU. I WAS JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT ABOUT IN OUR
DISTRICT, THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF
INDUSTRY AROUND THE PERFORMING
ARTS SPACE AND, NOT JUST, THE
PERFORMANCE SPACE ITSELF, BUT
ALL OF THE SURROUNDING
RESTAURANTS AND, SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN AND AROUND THESE
CENTERS. I'M CURIOUS, IS THERE A
SENSE OF HOW MANY WORKERS WOULD
BE IMPACTED BY THESE CUTS OF
12.5 MILLION IN TERMS OF JOB
LOSS, IF THE ADMINISTRATION WERE
TO TAKE THIS FUNDING BACK,
BECAUSE TYPICALLY WHEN YOU STOP
THE THEATER PRODUCTION, IT
AFFECTS A CERTAIN GROUP OF
WORKERS, BUT IT HAS A RIPPLE
EFFECT. SO I'M CURIOUS, JUST AT
THE POINT OF THE DEEPEST IMPACT,
WE HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT JOBS
WOULD BE LOST THROUGH THIS CUT.
SURE, LAUREN GREENWOOD WITH
GÓMEZ. SO, THE PERFORMING ARTS
EQUITABLE PAYROLL FUND WAS
ESTABLISHED IN OR, AND SIGNED
INTO LAW IN 2022. AND SO IT JUST
RECEIVED ITS FIRST APPROPRIATION
LAST YEAR. OUR TEAM WAS WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING
THOSE REPRESENTING THE ARTS
COMMUNITY, TO HELP, YOU KNOW,
THE PROGRAMS IN STATUTE, BUT
STILL NEEDS TO BE FURTHER
FLESHED OUT, AND TO, TO CREATE A
PROGRAM. SO, FOLKS COULD APPLY
AND GET THAT MONEY BACK TO THEIR
BUSINESSES AND SUPPORT THEIR
EMPLOYEES. SO AT THIS POINT,
THERE'S THEY ARE STILL IN
DISCUSSIONS ON HOW TO FORMULATE
THE PROGRAM AND, AND HOW MANY
WHAT SIZE OF GRANTS WOULD MAKE
SENSE FOR THE PROGRAM. SO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WERE ONGOING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. WE DON'T HAVE A
SENSE YET OF HOW MANY BUSINESSES
THIS WOULD SUPPORT, AND
THEREFORE HOW MANY EMPLOYEES, SO
BUT DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. AND AS THIS
PROGRAM POTENTIALLY COULD
RECEIVE A FUTURE APPROPRIATION.
SO THIS IS NOT ACTUALLY BEEN LET
OUT YET. SO THERE ARE NO PAYROLL
, ALL, DEBTS ON THIS FUNDING AT
THIS POINT. OKAY. THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
IF NOT WE'LL MOVE TO THE NEXT
ISSUE. THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD
SMALL AGRICULTURAL BUSINESS
DROUGHT RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM.
PLEASE PROCEED. CHARLES SAU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE 2022
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED $75 MILLION,
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE
DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO ELIGIBLE
GRANT TO TRY TO PROVIDE DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO ELIGIBLE
AGRICULTURAL RELATED BUSINESSES
AFFECTED BY SEVERE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS. THIS SOLUTION
REVERTS $5 MILLION FROM THIS
PROGRAM BACK TO THE GENERAL FUND
, AS THERE ARE RESOURCES
REMAINING IN THIS PROGRAM. LEO
ON THIS ITEM IN THE NEXT ONE, WE
THINK THAT, REVERTING UNUSED
FUNDS FROM ONE TIME ALLOCATIONS
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS, IS A GOOD
STARTING POINT FOR LOOKING FOR
BUDGET SOLUTIONS, BECAUSE THOSE
TYPES OF REVERSIONS TEND TO
HAVE, POTENTIALLY FEWER IMPACTS
THAN IF WE WERE TO MAKE CUTS
INTO ONGOING SPENDING. FAIR
POINT. BACK TO THE SUB. HOWEVER,
TO FOLLOW ON THAT, THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT IS WHY ARE THERE
REMAINING UNALLOCATED FUNDS AND
ARE THERE APPLICATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN AWARDED AND HAVEN'T OR
COULD BE? I MEAN, GIVEN THAT IT
IS A ONE TIME. SURE, LAUREN
GREENWOOD WITH GO-BIZ, SO, THE
THERE ARE TWO COMPONENTS TO THE
DROUGHT AND FLOOD PROGRAM, ONE
BEING THE $20 MILLION FOR FLOOD
AND THE SECOND BEING THE $75
MILLION FOR DROUGHT, WE'VE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT, DEMAND FOR THE FLAT
FOR THE FLOOD PRODUCT, IT'S THAT
PROGRAM WAS ACTUALLY FULLY
SUBSCRIBED. AND THERE'S, I
THINK, OF ALMOST $20 MILLION OF
EXCESS DEMAND THAT OUR OFFICE
JUST WASN'T ABLE TO FILL DUE TO
THE LIMITATION OF FUNDS, FOR THE
DROUGHT PROGRAM, THAT THERE IS
PRETTY STRICT CRITERIA IN BEING
HAVING, TO DEMONSTRATE A LOSS IN
REVENUES, AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE
BEEN IN BUSINESS PRIOR TO 2020.
AND SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO ACCESS THOSE FUNDS.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT, AND OUR
TEAM HAS WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON OUTREACH AND
MEETINGS AND TRYING TO SPREAD
THE WORD ABOUT ACCESS TO THESE
FUNDS, DESPITE THAT, THERE IS
STILL, NOT ENOUGH ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS THAT WERE INTERESTED
IN APPLYING FOR THE DROUGHT
PROGRAM. AND THEREFORE, THAT'S
THE REASON FOR THE EXCESS FUNDS.
ALL RIGHT. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE. SENATOR
SMALL ON THE OVERSUBSCRIPTION
OVER SUBSCRIPTION. SO WAS THERE
FUNDING DIVERTED TO ADDRESS THE
20 MILLION SHORTFALL IN THE
FLOODING, OR IS THIS JUST TO
PULL BACK ALL THE 5 MILLION IN
THE DROUGHT FUNDS? I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW THAT
HOW THE OVERSUBSCRIPTION WAS
ADDRESSED, GIVEN THE WEATHER AND
THE CLIMATE CHANGE. SURE. LAUREN
GREENWOOD WITH GO-BIZ,
UNFORTUNATELY, STATUTE IS PRETTY
STRICT ON HOW MUCH THE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE TO PUT INTO EACH
CATEGORY. SO, WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
SERVE THOSE THOSE THAT WERE
REQUESTING ASSISTANCE FOR FLOOD,
IN THAT EXCESS, BECAUSE THE
MONEY IS VERY, IT'S DEDICATED TO
DROUGHT. YEAH. IT JUST SEEMS
THAT THOSE SO THOSE FOLKS WERE
TURNED AWAY AND THIS FUNDING WAS
JUST UNTAPPED. OKAY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? IF NOT,
WE'LL MOVE TO THE NEXT ISSUE.
THAT ISSUE WILL BE HELD OPEN.
ISSUE 15 IS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BUDGET SUSTAINABILITY FUND.
PLEASE PROCEED. CHARLES LÀ SAU,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE 2023
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED $50 MILLION
TO SUPPORT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BUDGET SUSTAINABILITY FUND,
WHICH PROVIDE GRANTS TO COUNTIES
FACING SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES TO
NEAR-TERM BUDGET SUSTAINABILITY.
THIS SOLUTION REVERTS THE ENTIRE
$50 MILLION BACK TO THE GENERAL
FUND TO ALLOW NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
OTHER QUESTIONS. COMMENTS SEEING
NONE, WE'LL HOLD THAT ITEM AND
WE'LL MOVE TO OPR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ISSUE 16 IS
DEPARTMENT REORGANIZATION. WE'LL
GIVE FOLKS A COUPLE MINUTES HERE
TO RESHUFFLE
.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT, PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
FOR THE RECORD AND PROCEED WHEN
READY. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
PADILLA, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS RUSS FONG.
I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH, AND I DO
HAVE IN THE AUDIENCE ANTHONY
CHÁVEZ, OPERATION DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS. IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR HIM,
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY THE MAY
REVISE CHANGES AND IMPACT FOR 24
AND 25, THIS QUICK PRESENTATION
I'LL GIVE REALLY COVERS ITEMS
AND ISSUES NUMBER 16, 17 AND 18.
FIRST, THE MAY REVISE IS
IMPACTING THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH IN TWO
MAIN AREAS WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT TODAY. THE FIRST IS
THE REALIGNMENT OF THE OFFICE.
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET ENVISIONS THE
MOVEMENT OF A NUMBER OF OUR
PROGRAMS UNDER THE OPR UMBRELLA
TO OTHER STATE ENTITIES, AND A
REBRANDING OF OPR'S NAME. THE
SECOND IS THE CREATION OF A NEW
OFFICE SEPARATE FROM OPR, WHICH
WILL HOUSE THE STATE'S CRITICAL
OUTREACH AND VOLUNTEER EFFORTS
IN A MORE FOCUSED AND COHESIVE
WAY. THIS REALIGNMENT WILL SEE
THE FOLLOWING PROGRAMS WITHIN
OPR REASSIGNED TO EXISTING
AGENCIES, WHICH ARE BETTER
ALIGNED WITH THEIR POLICY
OBJECTIVES AND SUBJECT MATTERS.
FIRST, THE CALIFORNIA JOBS FIRST
WILL MOVE OVER TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, ZERO EMISSIONS
TRANSIT ROADMAP WILL ALSO MOVE
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AND THEN FINALLY
THE CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE TO
PRECISION MEDICINE WILL MOVE TO
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY AS PART OF THE
REALIGNMENT, THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH IS
PROPOSING A NAME CHANGE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF CLIMATE AND
LAND USE INNOVATION. THIS
RENAMING, ALONG WITH THE LARGER
RESTRUCTURING, CAPTURES THE
NATURE OF THE OFFICE'S FOCUS ON
DELIVERING THOUGHTFUL POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS AND OPERATING AS
AN AGILE FOCUS ON CREATING THE
BEST POSSIBLE FUTURE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THIS EFFORT IS
MEANT TO REALIGN OPERS WITH ITS
CORE FUNCTION AND MISSION OF
FOSTERING CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE GROWTH
THROUGH INFORMED AND EQUITABLE
LAND USE DECISIONS. THIS EFFORT
ALSO FOLLOWS OPRAH'S TRADITIONAL
ROLE AS AN INCUBATOR OF CUTTING
EDGE PROGRAMS, IDEAS, AND POLICY
EFFORTS WITHIN THE STATE, WITH
THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF PLACING
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS WITHIN
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS THAT
ALIGN WITH THOSE POLICY
OBJECTIVES. ALONG WITH THIS
REALIGNMENT, THE OPR IS CREATING
A CREATION OF A NEW AGENCY
CALLED AGAIN, THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF SERVICE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. THIS WILL COMPRISE
OF CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS, THE
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP
AND STRATEGIC COMMUNICATION, AND
THE YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
COMMISSION. THIS OFFICE WILL
PRESERVE THE CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS THE STATE HAS MADE
IN ITS OUTREACH AND VOLUNTEER
CAPACITY, WHILE PROVIDING A
VEHICLE TO ENHANCE THESE
EFFORTS. THIS REALIGNMENT
REPRESENTS NOT JUST A
RESHUFFLING OF PROGRAMS AND
OFFICES, BUT A STRATEGIC
INITIATIVE AIMED AT ENHANCING
EFFECTIVENESS, ACCOUNTABILITY
AND SERVICE DELIVERY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THESE
PROGRAMS. AND THEN LASTLY, THE
MAY REVISE PROPOSES GENERAL FUND
SOLUTIONS THAT IMPACT OPR. BUT
WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
SOLUTIONS WILL PRESERVE THE
PROGRAMS THAT OPR IS MAKING. OUR
EFFORT WILL CONTINUE PROVIDING
LASTING BENEFITS TO COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO CONTRIBUTING TO A BETTER
FISCAL OUTLOOK FOR THE STATE. WE
ARE EXCITED ABOUT THIS NEXT PAGE
IN OPR EVOLUTION AND WITH THAT,
I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THE
BUDGET SOLUTION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, HENRY AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, JUST TO CLARIFY, DID
YOU WANT TO PRESENT THE
SOLUTIONS TO THE DEPARTMENT, OR
WOULD YOU LIKE FOR US TO REMAIN
AT THIS ISSUE REGARDING THE
REORG, ON THE NEW YORK, AND I
JUST HAD A QUESTION FOR DOV. I
MEAN, WE'RE GETTING SOME OF THE,
ARTICULATION OF SOME OF THE
DETAIL HERE IN MAY REVISE. AND
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
SENSE OF URGENCY. ALSO WANT SOME
COMMENT FROM LAO FOLLOWING THAT
ON THE RATIONALE, MAYBE I'M
GETTING AHEAD OF MYSELF ON
PUTTING ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INTO GO-BIZ, BUT FEEL FREE.
THANK YOU. KUSHMARO WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE. WE
RECOMMEND THAT LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE PROPOSED
REORGANIZATION. THÀNH. AS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED, IT MAY REVISE
MAY NOT BE THE APPROPRIATE TIME
FOR DOING A REORGANIZATION. WE
DO NOTE THAT A REORGANIZATION
COULD HAVE MERIT, OPR HAS
EXPANDED CONSIDERABLY IN RECENT
YEARS DUE TO NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES PROVIDED TO IT,
INCLUDING ISSUING GRANTS,
IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION, AND
ADMINISTERING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
MORE IN LINE WITH THE
TRADITIONAL STATE DEPARTMENT. AS
SUCH, REORGANIZING OPR COULD
HAVE MERIT IN THE LONGER TERM.
AND COULD IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY BY HAVING
APPOINTED LEADERS WHO ARE
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE AND
STAFFED BY CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES. IN ADDITION, A
REORGANIZATION COULD BETTER
ALIGN FUNCTIONS WITH AGENCIES
THAT MIGHT HAVE MORE RELEVANT
SUBJECT EXPERTISE, AS THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS STATED. BUT
THE MAY REVISE PROVIDES LITTLE
TIME TO REVIEW THE PROPOSAL.
NOTABLY, THERE'S LITTLE TIME TO
EVALUATE THE POTENTIAL COSTS AND
TRADE OFFS INVOLVED IN THE
REORGANIZATION, AS WELL AS
ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF APPROACHING
IT. AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT WITH OPR, AS THEY
TOUCH ON MANY KEY PRIORITIES OF
THE LEGISLATURE, INCLUDING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CEQA
IMPLEMENTATION. BUT, WE WHILE WE
HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO PROVIDE AN
IN-DEPTH REVIEW OF THE POTENTIAL
COSTS OF THE PROPOSAL, WE NOTE
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS STATED
THAT IT WOULD BE COST NEUTRAL.
HOWEVER, TYPICALLY
REORGANIZATIONS HAVE RESULTED IN
INCREASED COSTS RELATED TO
ISSUES SUCH AS REALIGNED STAFF
AND RESPONSIBILITIES,
ESTABLISHING A NEW LEADERSHIP
TEAM, RELOCATING STAFF,
PURCHASING EQUIPMENT, AND
COVERING ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS. CONDUCTING SUCH AN
ANALYSIS OF THESE COSTS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT, SO THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE ORGANIZATION
MAKES SENSE FOR THEIR
PRIORITIES. IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET SITUATION WHERE WE DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH GENERAL FUND TO
COVER EXISTING STATE PRIORITIES,
AS SUCH, WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE PROPOSAL
WITHOUT PREJUDICE. IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES WANT TO, VISIT
THE ORGANIZATION IN THE FUTURE,
THEY COULD CONSIDER DIRECTING
THE ADMINISTRATION TO GO THROUGH
THE LITTLE HOOVER PROCESS, WHICH
IS ESTABLISHED IN THE STATE
CONSTITUTION IN. OR IT COULD
DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATION TO
COME FORWARD WITH A PROPOSAL,
EITHER THROUGH THE POLICY
PROCESS, WITH A LEGISLATIVE
SPONSOR OR THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR.
THANK YOU, AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. OKAY.
WE'LL BRING IT TO THE SUB,
SENATOR NHIÀU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, WITH REGARD TO THIS ITEM,
IN THE FOLLOWING TWO, I FRANKLY
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE TO START.
AS I READ THROUGH THIS, I HAD TO
SMILE, WITH A BIT OF, I GUESS,
COMIC ENTERTAINMENT. EXCUSE ME
FOR THAT. THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH, WHEN I LEFT THE
ASSEMBLY WAS A RELATIVELY SMALL
DEPARTMENT DEDICATED TO
PROVIDING SERVICE TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH RELATIVE TO
PLANNING AND RESEARCH. GENERAL,
MISSION BASED UPON THE NEEDS OF
THE TIME AND, SINCE THEN AND I
GUESS REALLY IN THE LAST SIX
YEARS OR SO, THE DEPARTMENT HAS
EXPLODED WITH SPECIFIC
INITIATIVES WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT, BASED UPON FRANKLY,
I'M NOT ENTIRELY SURE WHAT, AND
NOW WE'RE PROPOSING TO SHRINK
THE DEPARTMENT DOWN, PRESUMABLY
TO MORE WHAT IT WAS LIKE BEFORE.
BUT WE'RE CHANGING ITS NAME.
THAT COMPLETELY BETRAYS THAT. AS
I SAID, IT WAS A, PROVIDED THE
GENERAL SERVICES OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH ANALYSIS TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH. AND NOW WE'RE
CALLING IT THE OFFICE OF CLIMATE
AND LAND USE INNOVATION, MEANING
IT'S JUST GOING TO ADVISE, OR
THINK ABOUT ISSUES WITH REGARD
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND LAND USE
ISSUES. I HAVE TO SAY, THIS
WHOLE THING MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO
SENSE TO ME AT. AND THE
EXPLOSION OF THE DEPARTMENT HAS
HAPPENED INCREMENTALLY AT
DIFFERENT TIMES, AND SEEMINGLY
NONE OF THEM, COORDINATED IN
ANY, THOUGHT OF IN ANY
COORDINATED FASHION. AND IT
WOULD SEEM TO ME WE NOT ONLY
REJECT THIS, BUT TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT HAS HAPPENED, WHY IT HAS
HAPPENED, AND SHOULD IT HAVE
HAPPENED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THIS HAPPENED IN, IN RATHER
FLUSH BUDGET YEARS, TO WHICH I
HAVE SUGGESTED THAT ONE OF THE
WAYS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO CUT
BACK FOR THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR
AND THE NEXT FEW IS TO GO BACK
TO THE TO THE BUDGET YEARS,
WHERE WE HAD A HUGE SURPLUSES
AND ASK TWO QUESTIONS. ONE IS,
WHAT WOULD WE HAVE NOT DONE HAD
WE HAD A MORE EVEN REVENUE
STREAM? AND THEN ASIDE FROM THAT
, WHAT HAS BEEN THE RESULT OF
NEW SPENDING, EITHER NEW
SPENDING ON EXISTING PROGRAMS OR
NEW PROGRAMS THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED DURING THAT TIME,
WHAT HAVE THEY ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISHED? AND THROUGH THOSE
QUESTIONS, WE'D PROBABLY COME UP
WITH MANY MORE PROGRAM
REDUCTIONS THAN CURRENTLY EXIST
IN THE MAY REVISE AS. BUT MAYBE
THERE ARE QUESTIONS IN THERE.
MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS WHAT I'VE
SAID, THE IT JUST SEEMS TO ME TO
BE UNCOORDINATED AND, UNTRULY
THOUGHT THROUGH FROM A, OVERALL
STANDPOINT. AND WE HAVE
COMPLETELY THAT WHICH WAS
ORIGINALLY A, A USEFUL, SERVICE
TO THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND HAVE
, AS I SAID, TOTALLY THAT MODEL.
SO, SENATOR NEAL, I JUST, FIRST
OF ALL, WANT TO MAKE SURE I WAS
CLEAR. THE, OPI ARE STILL AROUND
THE OPR, INSTITUTION WILL STILL
BE WAS GOING TO BE NAMED THE
OFFICE OF CLIMATE AND LAND USE
INNOVATION. WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING
IS A REALIGNMENT OF AN EXISTING
PROGRAM WITHIN THREE PROGRAMS
WITHIN OPR TO A NEW ENTITY. SO
WE'LL HAVE THE OPR, WHICH WILL
BE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
CLIMATE AND LAND USE INNOVATION.
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE A NEW ENTITY
CALLED THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
SERVICE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT, WHICH WE TOOK OUR
CORE FUNCTIONS THAT ARE BETTER,
BASICALLY FOCUSED ON COMMUNITY
ALIGNMENTS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE COMMUNITY ALIGNMENT
PROGRAMS STATEWIDE ARE ALL
WORKING COHESIVELY AND TOGETHER.
SO OPR IS STILL HERE, WE'RE
GOING TO CREATE A NEW FUNCTION
THAT'S BETTER ALIGNED ON, AGAIN,
FOCUSING SOLELY ON STATEWIDE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. AND, AS
FAR AS THE GROWTH, I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH YOU, OUR BUDGET IN 20
1617 WAS $54 MILLION, TODAY IT'S
PROPOSED TO BE OVER $800
MILLION. SO I AGREE, WE BECOME
WE'VE TAKEN ON A LOT. I THINK
THAT TERM THINK TANK HAS POPPED
UP AND USED A LOT, WHICH IS ALSO
WHY WE WANT TO HAVE GO BACK TO
OUR REBRANDING EFFORT, WHICH IS
TO REALLY FOCUS ON WHAT OUR KEY
CORE MISSIONS ARE, WHICH IS
CLIMATE AND LAND USE, SO
PARTIALLY AGREE WITH SOME OF
YOUR COMMENTS, AND WE'RE TRYING
TO GET BACK TO WHAT WE DO
REALLY, REALLY WELL, AND ALSO
REALIGN FOR SUCCESS OUR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS AND
WITH THE NEW OFFICE. SO, WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS ACCOUNTABILITY
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID TO GET
BETTER AT WHAT WE DO AND NOT
JUST JUST TOUCH EVERY SINGLE
THING WE WANT TO GET BACK TO OUR
INCREASED PERFORMANCE AND BE
ABLE TO BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE. AND
THAT'S REALLY THE DRIVER BEHIND
THIS REORG RIGHT NOW. AND IT'S
REALLY MORE OF A REALIGNMENT, WE
DON'T PLAN. WE'RE PLANNING USING
ALL EXISTING STAFF AS OF TODAY,
THINGS COULD CHANGE. BUT RIGHT
NOW IT'S ALL EXISTING STAFF.
WE'RE STILL IN THE SAME BUILDING
, WE DON'T ANTICIPATE MUCH OR
ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS. IT'S JUST
REALLY FOCUSING ON WHAT OUR KEY
OBJECTIVES ARE AND TO BETTER
REALIGN SO THAT WE ARE WE'RE
ABLE TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL AND
BE MORE ACCOUNTABLE. THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT TO DO. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. SO WHAT
I HEARD YOU SAY IS YOUR FOCUSING
OR REFOCUSING, THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH, AND YOU
MENTIONED TWO ORGANIZATIONAL
NAMES. ONE IS CITED HERE, THE
CLIMATE AND LAND USE INNOVATION.
YOU ALSO MENTIONED A COMMUNITY,
SOMETHING. YEAH. SO OPR WOULD BE
THE CLIMATE AND LAND USE
INNOVATION OFFICE, THE SECOND
OFFICE IS GROUPS PROGRAMS WITH
ALREADY THERE IN OPR. WE PROPOSE
TO SEPARATE THOSE AND CREATE
THAT SYNERGY WHICH WILL THAT
OFFICE WOULD BE CALLED THE
OFFICE OF SERVICE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. AND THEIR SOLE FOCUS
WOULD BE ON COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
OF PROGRAMS STATEWIDE. AND THEY
HAVE THAT SAME MISSION AND
VISION AND WE THINK THOSE GROUPS
WILL WORK BETTER TOGETHER.
HOWEVER WE STILL CAN. WE STILL
BE UNDER THE SAME FACILITY, OUR
ADMIN SHOPS, I.T SHOPS, ALL
THOSE WILL STILL BE THE SAME.
IT'S JUST MORE OF A SYNERGY
REALIGNMENT, NOT NECESSARILY
CREATING A WHOLE NEW ADMIN TEAM
AND OPERATIONS TEAM. IT'LL STILL
BE THE SAME FOLKS SERVICING THIS
JUST IN A BETTER ALIGNMENT. WE
BELIEVE. HOW CAN IT BE THE SAME
FOCUS AS IT WAS TEN YEARS AGO
WHEN OPR HAD A GENERAL FOCUS,
DEPENDING UPON ISSUES THAT CAME
UP? THE ISSUES, ALL SORTS OF
ISSUES COME UP FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND ELSEWHERE IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH NEEDS A
CAPABILITY TO ANALYZE THAT. BUT
YOU HAVE NARROWED IT NOW TO JUST
, CLIMATE AND LAND USE
INNOVATION. THERE SEEMS TO BE A
FONDNESS FOR THAT. THAT WORD
INNOVATION, BUT JUST CLIMATE AND
LAND USE AND THEN COMMUNITY
FOCUSED ISSUES. WHAT ABOUT ALL
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT CAN COME
UP, THOSE WON'T BE ADDRESSED.
OBVIOUSLY. WE'LL ADDRESS
WHATEVER INITIATIVE COMES OUR
WAY. BUT AGAIN, IT IS I THINK
THE DRIVER THAT WE WANT TO DO IS
TO BE REALLY ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THOSE KEY FUNCTIONS AND THOSE
CORE FUNCTIONS THAT WE'VE ALWAYS
HAD, THE SEQUA AND LAND USE AND
CLIMATE PROGRAMS. SO IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF TAKING AWAY SO MUCH,
BUT REALLY GETTING BACK TO
GETTING MORE ACCOUNTABLE AND
MORE FOCUSED ON THE THINGS THAT
WE DO REALLY, REALLY WELL AND
CREATE SOME SYNERGY ON COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT, AND AGAIN, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THESE ARE
REALIGNMENTS OF OR AN
ORGANIZATION, WE'RE STILL THE
SAME FOLKS, THE SAME PEOPLE, THE
SAME RESOURCE AND THE SAME
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ON
NEW INITIATIVES. IF THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TOLD TO DO. SO WE'RE NOT
TAKING AWAY ANYTHING. I THINK
WE'RE GETTING BETTER AND
BECOMING MORE ACCOUNTABLE, WHICH
WE FELT WAS A LITTLE DIFFICULT.
AND THE FACT THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
AGREE WITH YOU, WE GREW QUITE A
BIT IN A RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME. WELL, I GUESS IT'S A
STATEMENT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BEHALF. AND ON
AND FOR THEREFORE, ON BEHALF OF
FUTURE ADMINISTRATIONS, IS THAT
THE FOCUS IS CLIMATE, LAND USE
AND THEN COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT,
WHICH WOULD TEND TO DEPRIORITIZE
OTHER THINGS THAT COULD COME UP,
IF THOSE ARE THE TRUE, FOCUS IS.
THE OTHER POINT IS THAT, YOU
ADDRESSED THE FACT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS GROWN EXPLOSIVELY
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS, BECOMING,
AS THE STAFF REPORT SAYS, A BIT
OF A FRANKENSTEIN DEPARTMENT.
AND SO THE ATTEMPT, I GUESS, IS
TO DEMONSTRATE IT, AND ASSIGN
THOSE INDIVIDUAL, FUNCTIONS TO
DEPARTMENT WHERE THEY APPEAR TO
BE MORE RELEVANT. AND ONE WOULD
HAVE TO RAISE THE QUESTION, WHY
WEREN'T THEY ESTABLISHED THERE
IN THE FIRST PLACE? AND AS I
SAID BEFORE, IT WOULD SEEM TO
BEG AN ANALYSIS. TIME OUT. LET'S
ASSESS WHAT WE'VE DONE, WHAT
RESULTS THEY'VE PRODUCED, AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD EVEN
CONTINUE ANY OF THOSE. SO IT
JUST WOULD NOT MAKE SENSE TO ME
TO APPROVE THIS AS IS. NOT TO
MENTION THE RATHER LATE NATURE
OF THE PROPOSAL. SENATOR NILO,
SENATOR SMALL, DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ON THIS? ALL RIGHT, I
THINK YOU GET THE POINT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
PRESENTATION. WE WILL WE WILL
TAKE EACH ISSUE ONE AT A TIME.
WE'LL MOVE TO STAFF AND
BUDGETARY AUGMENTATIONS
ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATED WITH
TRANSITION TO CIVIL SERVICE ON
ISSUE 17, IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL PRESENTATION, PLEASE
PROCEED. NÓ THE OTHER TWO. BCP'S
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY UNIT
FOUNDATION IS REALLY TO CONTINUE
THE DEPARTMENT'S IT UNIT SUPPORT
AND OVERSIGHT AND ADMINISTRATION
OF AN IT SHOP. WE DID RELY ON A
THIRD PARTY ENTITY. AND THEN WE
OBVIOUSLY GREW OUTGREW THAT
NEED. SO WE NOW HAVE OUR OWN IT
DEPARTMENT. THIS REQUEST IS JUST
FOR DOLLARS ONLY, NOT POSITIONS,
JUST TO KEEP THE INFRASTRUCTURE
UP AND RUNNING. IT'S YOUR BASIC
EMAIL INFRASTRUCTURE ITEMS THAT
WERE REQUESTED, THE
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOAD, AS YOU
KNOW, IN BUILDING A STATE
OFFICE, IT'S LIKE BUILDING A
HOUSE. YOU NEED, SOMEONE THAT
BUILDS THE FLOOR, THE WALLS, THE
ROOF, EVERYTHING. SO THESE ARE
JUST THE MINIMUM REQUESTS TO
CREATE AN AIR SHOP, NOW THAT
WE'RE MOVING INTO A CIVIL
SERVICE DEPARTMENT, ABOUT 41% OF
OUR EMPLOYEES NOW ARE CIVIL
SERVICE. AND WE HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THOSE REQUIREMENTS, WHICH
IS WHY WE'RE REQUESTING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITIONS. THANK
YOU. ELIO THANK YOU, THE
ADMINISTRATION INDICATES THAT
THE PROPOSALS FOR THESE
RESOURCES ARE NOT RELATED TO THE
REORGANIZATION. HOWEVER, PAST
REORGANIZATIONS HAVE TYPICALLY
RESULTED IN CHANGES TO NEEDS FOR
SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH AS
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES, FOR
EXAMPLE, AND THIS REORGANIZATION
COULD AS WELL. FOR EXAMPLE, IF
CERTAIN RESPONSIBILITIES SUCH AS
PRECISION MEDICINE ARE MOVED TO
ANOTHER EXISTING DEPARTMENT, THE
RECEIVING ENTITY MIGHT NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WHILE THE
RECONSTITUTED OPR MAY NEED LESS
RESOURCES. SIMILARLY, CREATING A
NEW AND SEPARATE OFFICE KOTZEV
LIKELY WOULD RESULT IN NEW AND
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE NEEDS. GIVEN
THIS, WE FIND THE PROPOSAL
PREMATURE AND WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
PROPOSAL, AND WHETHER AND WHEN
IT MAKES CHANGES IN HOW THE
DEPARTMENT'S ACTIVITIES ARE
ORGANIZED ACROSS THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND A DETAILED
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED AND MAY BE APPROPRIATE
TO DETERMINE WHAT RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED AT THAT TIME. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. BRING IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. SENATOR NHIÀU. IN
THE PREVIOUS ITEM, IT IS STATED
THAT THE FINANCE LETTER,
INDICATES THAT THIS WILL RESULT
IN NET ZERO IMPACTS ON STATE
RESOURCES. AND YET IN THE VERY
FOLLOWING ITEM, AND THE ONE
AFTER THAT TOO, BUT IN THIS ONE,
THE REQUEST IS FOR, ABOUT $1
MILLION AND SIX NEW POSITIONS.
I'M CONFUSED BY THAT. YEAH,
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION, SENATOR
AEILLO, THIS REQUEST IS RELATED
TO THE FACT THAT WE'RE
TRANSITIONING FROM A TRADITIONAL
OR AN UNTRADITIONAL, GOVERNOR
TYPE APPOINTEE POSITION, AS
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH, TO A CIVIL
SERVICE DEPARTMENT. AND SO
REGARDLESS OF THE REORG, OR IF
WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT ON THE
TABLE, WE WOULD STILL NEED THESE
RESOURCES. AGAIN, WE HAVE ABOUT
41. OVER HALF OUR STAFF ARE
CIVIL SERVANTS. WE ACTUALLY NEED
FOLKS, YOU KNOW, FOR INSURE
TRANSACTIONS, WE HAVE TO RECRUIT
PEOPLE FOR RECRUITMENT, TRAINING
AND, DEVELOPMENT. WE HAVE A
PAYROLL TRANSACTION UNIT. WE
HAVE EEO LABOR RELATIONS. SO
THESE FOLKS ARE TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE THAT HOUSE, THAT HR SHOP
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES. AND THE SAME GOES
WITH THE I.T SHOP. THESE ARE
JUST YOUR BASIC MINIMUM. NOTHING
FANCY YOUR EMAILS AND JUST
THINGS TO KEEP OUR DAY TO DAY
JOB GOING FORWARD. AGAIN, THESE
TWO COSTS WOULD OCCUR REGARDLESS
OF WHAT WE DO WITH THE
REORGANIZATION, THIS IS JUST TO
KEEP THE DATE, KEEP OUR LIGHTS
ON, AS I WOULD SAY. YOU REALIZE,
OF COURSE, HOW THIS CREATES SOME
CONFUSION. I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND. I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
. AND IT BEGS THE QUESTION
AGAIN, I THINK TO THE SENATOR'S
POINT, THAT WE'RE ASSERTING A
NEW NET COST. BUT EVEN WITH
SIGNIFICANT TRANSFER OUT OF
DEPARTMENT AND OFTENTIMES THOSE
IN THOSE COSTS ARE ASSESSED
BASED ON PERSONNEL DEMAND, FTE,
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
CIVIL SERVICE COMPLIANCE. SO YOU
CAN SEE HOW THAT SEEMS A LITTLE
MISALIGNED. ALL RIGHT. ANY
FURTHER COMMENT FROM THE SUB.
ALL RIGHT. THAT ITEM BE HELD.
MOVE TO ISSUE 18 FUNDING FOR IT.
ADDITIONAL ON THAT. THOUSAND
DOLLAR. WE HAVEN'T COVERED. DID
YOU HAVE COMMENT ON 18
ADDITIONAL COMMENT. FOR THE
SIMILAR REASONS AS THE LAST
ISSUE, WE RECOMMEND REJECTING
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. BACK
TO THE SUB QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS. LAWCENTER ISSUE
18. YEAH THANK YOU. I THINK WE
COVERED IT, BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S NOTHING WE
LEFT OUTSTANDING. SO I GUESS I'D
HAVE THE SAME STATEMENT AS
BEFORE. NET ZERO CALL ON STATE
RESOURCES AND THEN TWO ITEMS
THAT ARE ASKING FOR INCREASED
FUNDING. AND ANOTHER QUESTION OF
A BIT MORE GENERAL NATURE. BUT
RELATED TO THIS, THE PART OF THE
MAY REVISE WAS A ELIMINATION OF
VACANT POSITIONS AND AN 8%
ROUGHLY ACROSS THE BOARD,
REDUCTION IN SPENDING TO BE
SPECIFIED BY RELEVANT AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS WILL APPEAR BE
PARTICIPATING IN BOTH OF THOSE
ACTIONS, TO MY KNOWLEDGE. YES.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE IMPACT FROM
OPR WILL BE RELATIVE TO EACH OF
THOSE, NO, WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
DETAILS, BUT WE WILL HAVE THAT
ANALYSIS ONCE WE WORK WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO FIND
OUT SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE
DETAILS ARE. DO YOU HAVE VACANT
POSITIONS, YES. WE DO CURRENTLY
HAVE SOME VACANT POSITIONS.
ABOUT HOW MANY, I WOULD SAY DUE
TO THE TRANSITION, SO AGAIN, I
CAN SEE THE CONFUSION AND I WANT
TO, FIRST OF ALL, APOLOGIZE TO
THE COMMUNITY, COMMITTEE, WE HAD
PLANNED ON TRANSITIONING TO A
STATE CIVIL SERVICE DEPARTMENT
COMPLETELY SEPARATE A WHILE AGO.
SO THAT'S BEEN LONG UNDERWAY.
THE REASON THE RESOURCES ARE
BECOMING NOW FOR THE ADMIN, AND
IT IS BECAUSE WE NOW HAVE CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYEES. WE NEVER HAD
THAT BEFORE. SO THAT'S THE
URGENCY TO HAVE THE FUNDS AND
THE RESOURCE HR SHOP AND THE IT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THOSE
CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS. AND
AGAIN, THAT IS SEPARATE FROM THE
REALIGNMENT AND RESTRUCTURING
AND REORGANIZING. SO I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT CONFUSION,
BUT THE TIMING JUST KIND OF HIT
THE SAME TIME. SO I SEE WHERE
THE CONFUSION IS, REGARDING THE
VACANCY RATES, AS WE TRANSITION,
IT REQUIRES US TO PUT A HOLD ON
POSITIONS AND TRANSITION WHAT WE
NORMALLY CALL A EXEMPT POSITIONS
TO CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS, SO I
WANT TO SAY OUR OUR VACANCY RATE
IS RELATIVELY HIGH RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THE TRANSITION, BUT
WE'RE NOW IN THE PHASE OF
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING AND,
RECRUITING FOR THOSE POSITIONS,
AND WE'RE FILLING THEM PRETTY
FAST. AND I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF
APPLICATIONS FOR THESE TYPE OF
POSITIONS. SO, OUR VACANCY RATE,
I WANT TO SAY IS RELATIVELY HIGH
BECAUSE OF NOT BECAUSE WE
COULDN'T FILL THEM OR WE DIDN'T
ADVERTISE THEM. WE HAD TO
TRANSITION THEM. BUT NOW THAT
THEY'RE BEING POSTED FOR THE
FIRST TIME, WE'RE FINDING A HUGE
AMOUNT OF APPLICANTS, QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS, AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT. SO YOU HAVE VACANT
POSITIONS THAT NOW SUBSEQUENT TO
THE MAY REVISE, DICTATING,
MANDATING THAT VACANT POSITIONS
BE ELIMINATED, YOU'RE GOING TO
FILL THEM, UNTIL WE'RE TOLD NOT
TO, THESE ARE POSITIONS THAT WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH FINANCE THAT
WERE TRANSITIONING AGAIN, THESE
WERE GOING THROUGH A TRANSITION
OF BEING IN WHAT WE CALL AN
EXEMPT POSITION TO A CIVIL
SERVICE POSITION. THESE WERE
THESE WERE PURPOSELY PUT ON HOLD
FOR THAT TRANSITION. AND NOW
THAT WE'VE CONVERTED THEM OVER
WORKING WITH H.R, WE'RE NOW ABLE
TO POST THOSE POSITIONS, BUT
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD UNTIL WE'RE
TOLD OTHERWISE. BUT YES, WE WILL
PARTICIPATE AS NEEDED ON
WHATEVER THE RESTRICTIONS ARE
GOING FORWARD. ONE WOULD HAVE TO
WONDER NOT TO OPR, BUT TO
FINANCE. TO WHAT EXTENT, SIMILAR
SITUATIONS EXIST IN OTHER
DEPARTMENT WHERE THERE ARE
VACANT POSITIONS, AND WE'RE
GOING TO FILL THEM ANYWAY, I'D
BE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT, YOU
INDICATED THAT THAT IS GOING
BACK TO THE, PRIOR ITEM THAT
YOU'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT. THE
CIVIL SERVICE ISSUE FOR A WHILE,
AND YET YOU PROPOSE IT 30 DAYS
BEFORE THE BUDGET'S DUE. DOES
THAT MAKE SENSE? YEAH, HENRY.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO, AS
OPRAH TOUCHED ON THE TRANSITION
FROM EXEMPTIONS TO CIVIL
POSITIONS, ACTUALLY, BEGAN IN
THE TRANSITION PROPOSED IN THE
2023 BUDGET ACT, SO THIS HAS
BEEN ONGOING, AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING
NOW AND THIS IS NOW THE NEXT
STEP IN THAT PROCESS. WELL, I
REALIZE ONE OF THE NATURES OF
GOVERNMENT IS IT MOVES RATHER
SLOW, WHICH IS NOT A BAD THING.
MAYBE WE OUGHT TO DO THAT IN
THIS CASE, TO. I'M CURIOUS HOW,
WITH RESPECT TO THE TECH UNIT,
HOW ARE WE DRAWING A DISTINCTION
ON THE DEMANDS OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH RESPECT TO
HOW DOES A CIVIL HOW DOES A
CLASSIFIED CIVIL SERVICE PERSON,
BELL EMPLOYEE DRAW A DIFFERENT
DEMAND ON THE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAN AN
UNCLASSIFIED NON CIVIL SERVANT?
YES. THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
DEMAND AND THEN DRAW A DIFFERENT
COST. LIKE NOT QUITE
UNDERSTANDING THAT CHAIR
PADILLA. SO AND SO PADILLA I'M
SORRY. NOT AT ALL. APOLOGIES.
CIVIL SERVICE REQUIRES A AGAIN
IT'S LIKE BUILDING A HOUSE FOR
IT. AND ADMIN YOU HAVE TO HAVE
CERTAIN POSITIONS TO BE ABLE TO
DO CERTAIN THINGS LIKE PROCESS
YOUR PAYROLL OR DO TRAINING
DEVELOPMENT. THOSE ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE THOSE POSITIONS. IN THE
PAST, FOLKS JUST KIND OF DID
WHAT THEY HAD TO DO TO KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON. BUT NOW THAT WE HAVE
A CIVIL SERVICE DEPARTMENT,
WE'RE REQUIRED AND TO BE
COMPLIANT TO HAVE CERTAIN
POSITIONS DOING CERTAIN THINGS
LIKE THE EEO OFFICER, LABOR
RELATIONS, THOSE THINGS WE
DIDN'T HAVE IN THE PAST WERE
REQUIRED TO HAVE THOSE NOW. AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEING TODAY
FOR THE INCREASE IN POSITIONS IS
TO BE COMPLIANT WITHIN CIVIL
SERVICE. BUT THAT'S NOT DRAWING
THE DISTINCTION TO IT. SO IT WE
WERE WE OUR ORIGINAL SERVICES
WERE FROM ANOTHER ENTITY THAT WE
OUTGREW. SO THE DECISION WAS
MADE TO MOVE IT IN-HOUSE TO OPR.
SO THIS IS A BRAND NEW I.T
DIVISION THAT'S GOING TO SUPPORT
OCR, GOING FORWARD. AND SO WE
HAVE BASICALLY BROUGHT OUR I.T
SHOP IN-HOUSE. SO I HAVE SOME
COMMENT JUST TO PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFYING COMMENTS. AND LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET PACKAGE, THERE WAS
A PROPOSAL TO SEPARATE THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT SUPPORT THAT OCR
RECEIVING FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO CREATE THEIR OWN
STANDALONE LEÓN INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES UNIT. AND
THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF LAST
YEAR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
ADDITIONAL IT NEEDS. THAT'S
HELPFUL. THE ADDITIONAL COMMENT
FOR HENRY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
AS LEO TOUCHED ON THE 2023
BUDGET, I PROVIDED THE POSITION
COR TO ESTABLISH THEIR OWN I.T
UNIT, AND THIS PROPOSAL IS TO
PROVIDE THEM AN ONGOING BASELINE
I.T INFRASTRUCTURE. SO THESE
RESOURCES WILL ALLOW THEM TO
ADDRESS, NEEDS IN NETWORKING,
CLOUD SERVICES, LICENSING,
SECURITY AND HARDWARE. AS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS PREPARED TO
PULL THEIR SUPPORT TO THE SUB
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT. THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD
MOVED TO ITEM 19, WHICH IS
REDUCTIONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION LEARNING LAB. AND
WE'LL GIVE FOLKS A SECOND TO
RESHUFFLE. THANK YOU.
WELCOME. AND PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. GOOD MORNING. I'M UMMON
SINGH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU. THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
REDUCING THE GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION LEARNING LAB BY $5.5
MILLION IN 2024, 25 AND 20 2526.
THE LEARNING LAB CURRENTLY HAS A
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION OF
AROUND $8 MILLION PER YEAR TO
OPERATE THIS REDUCTION IS
PROPOSED AS A BUDGETARY SOLUTION
IN LIGHT OF THE CURRENT FISCAL
ENVIRONMENT. ALL RIGHT. HELLO.
WE HAVE NOT RAISED CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. TO THE SUB QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL HOLD
THAT ITEM OPEN. WE'LL MOVE TO
THE ISSUE 20 GOLDEN STATE AWARDS
. PLEASE PROCEED. UMMON SINGH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION, THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
REVERTING $9.9 MILLION FROM THE
GOLDEN STATE AWARDS PROGRAM BACK
TO THE GENERAL FUND. THE 2022
BUDGET ACT PROVIDED $10 MILLION
FOR THIS PROGRAM, AND NEARLY THE
ENTIRE AMOUNT OF THAT IS
PROPOSED TO BE REVERTED. THANK
YOU. ALLOW WE DO NOT HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU TO THE SUB QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE US
SENATOR JENSEN. ALL RIGHT. THAT
ITEM WILL BE HELD. ALL RIGHT.
SCHOLARS SHARE INVESTMENT FUND
IS UP NEXT.
AGAIN, PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
FOR THE RECORD AND PROCEED WHEN
READY. I'M UMMON SINGH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
PULLING BACK $5 MILLION IN
ONGOING GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
PROVIDED TO THE CALIFORNIA KIDS
INVESTMENT AND DEVELOPMENT
SAVINGS PROGRAM, BETTER KNOWN AS
CAL KIDS. THESE FUNDS WERE
ORIGINALLY PROVIDED FOR
FINANCIAL LITERACY OUTREACH
EFFORTS. CAL KIDS IS A
CHILDREN'S SAVINGS ACCOUNT
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
SCHOLARSHARE INVESTMENT BOARD.
FINANCE DETERMINED THAT THIS $5
MILLION REDUCTION WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO HELP BRIDGE THE
BUDGET GAP. LÀ WITH THE LÀ, THE
FINANCIAL LITERACY OUTREACH
PROGRAM FOR CAL KIDS REMAINS
UNDER DEVELOPMENT, AND SO
DISCONTINUING IT AT THIS EARLY
STAGE IS ONE OF THE LESS
DISRUPTIVE OPTIONS THE STATE HAS
FOR ACHIEVING ONGOING SAVINGS.
SO WITH THAT IN MIND, WE
RECOMMEND REMOVING THE 5 MILLION
ONGOING AS THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES. IN ADDITION, WE
RECOMMEND REVERTING ANY FUNDS
PROVIDED IN PREVIOUS YEARS THAT
REMAIN UNSPENT. THIS WOULD ADD
9.5 MILLION IN 1 TIME SAVINGS ON
TOP OF THE MAY REVISION. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, BRING IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. ARE THERE
QUESTIONS? SENATOR SMALLWOOD?
CUEVAS JUST A QUICK QUESTION.
HOW MANY CALIFORNIANS HAVE A CAL
KIDS ACCOUNT? AND YOU MENTIONED
LEO, THE UNSPENT FUNDING. CAN
YOU EXPLAIN WHY THOSE DOLLARS
WERE NOT SPENT? NOAH LIGHTMAN
WITH THE SCHOLARSHARE INVESTMENT
BOARD, SO APPROXIMATELY 4
MILLION PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE CAL
KIDS ACCOUNTS, THERE'S A NEWBORN
COMPONENT TO THE PROGRAM AND A
STUDENT COMPONENT, WITH REGARDS
TO THE NON EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS,
WE WEREN'T GIVEN POSITION
AUTHORITY TO HIRE SOMEONE TO
WORK ON THIS FINANCIAL LITERACY
INITIATIVE UNTIL THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. AND IT TOOK UNTIL
NOVEMBER FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
HIRE A QUALIFIED PERSON, AND SO
JUST GIVEN OUR LIMITED STAFF
CAPACITY, WE'VE BEEN SO FOCUSED
ON THE GENERAL OPERATION OF THE
CAL KIDS PROGRAM AS IT IS,
REGARDLESS OF THE FINANCIAL
LITERACY EFFORT, THAT NOW THAT
WE HAVE SOMEONE IN PLACE, OUR
PLAN IS TO WORK ON A BROADER
PLAN TO ENGAGE PEOPLE THAT
ALREADY HAVE CAL KIDS ACCOUNTS.
ALL RIGHT. ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT. ITEM
WILL BE HELD. THANK YOU. MOVE TO
ISSUE 22. LOCAL JURISDICTION
RETAIL ACCESS GRANT PROGRAM.
WELCOME. AND PROCEED WHENEVER
READY. CHARLENE. CHARLENE
MANNING, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ASSISTANT. CLOSING THE PROJECTED
SHORTFALL. MAY REVISION PROPOSES
TO REVERT 16,470,023 24 FOR THE
CANNABIS LOCAL JURISDICTION
RETAIL ACCESS PROGRAM, WHICH IS
APPROPRIATED 20 MILLION IN THE
2022 BUDGET ACT. THIS REVISION
REFLECTS THE UNOBLIGATED BALANCE
OF THE PROGRAM AND WILL NOT
IMPACT THE FUNDING PROVIDED TO
AWARDEES. THANK YOU. NO COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT. TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, DO WE
HAVE A SENSE OF HOW THIS,
REVERTING OF FUNDS WILL IMPACT
THE SOCIAL EQUITY, SECTOR CARE
OF THE, CANNABIS COMMUNITY? WE
WE'VE SEEN IN SO MANY WAYS HOW
THOSE PARTICULAR CANNABIS
ENTREPRENEURS, ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED AND
LEFT OUT OF OPPORTUNITY. AND SO
THIS LOOKS LIKE THIS IS A DEEPER
CUT IN THAT OPPORTUNITY. JUST
CURIOUS WHAT WE THINK THE IMPACT
WILL BE AND ALSO HOW MANY
APPLICATIONS, HAVE YOU CURRENTLY
RECEIVED IN THIS PHASE TWO
EFFORT? THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. MY NAME IS ANGELA
HILL, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL,
FOR PHASE TWO, I'LL START THERE.
WE RECEIVED, ONE APPLICATION
THAT WE'VE AWARDED FUNDING TO
THAT WILL NOT BE IMPACTED BY
THIS PROPOSAL, ON YOUR QUESTION,
COMMENTS AROUND EQUITY WE MADE
EQUITY SOMETHING THAT IF A
APPLICANT IN PHASE ONE OR PHASE
TWO INDICATED THEY'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH AN EQUITY PROGRAM,
THAT THERE WAS ELIGIBLE BONUS
FUNDING FOR THEM IN PHASE ONE,
WE HAD 12 JURISDICTIONS OUT OF
THE TOTAL, 15 THAT HAVE BEEN
AWARDED FUNDING THAT, OPTED TO
DO THIS. SO THIS EQUITY FUNDING,
IS AVAILABLE FOR THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO FOLD IN FOR,
FEE WAIVERS FOR DEVELOPING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. NONE OF THAT
WILL BE IMPACTED, BY THIS
PROPOSED REVERSION. SO IN OTHER
WORDS, THE AWARDEES THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE, THE 12 OUT OF THE
15 FROM PHASE ONE, THEY ALL GET
TO KEEP THAT EQUITY FUNDING THAT
WE'VE AWARDED THEM, AND THEN
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS, OF
COURSE, ON THE STATE DOING MORE.
BUT AT LEAST UNDER THIS PLAN,
ALL OF THOSE JURISDICTIONS
AWARDED, THE EQUITY BONUS
FUNDING WILL CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
THAT MONEY FROM THE DEPARTMENT.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN ON PHASE TWO WHY
ONLY ONE APPLICANT? IS IT JUST
THE TIMING, THE TIMING? SO THIS
PROGRAM WAS INTENDED TO END, BE
ROLLED OUT AND CONTINUE TO HAVE
ROLLING APPLICATIONS. PHASE TWO
IS REALLY DEPENDENT UPON HOW
MANY, RETAIL LICENSES ISSUED.
WHEREAS PHASE ONE WAS STANDING
UP THE PROGRAM. IT TAKES A VERY
LONG TIME. MANY JURISDICTIONS
EXPERIENCE TO STAND UP A EQUITY
RETAIL PROGRAM. SO UNDER PHASE
ONE, YOU HAVE TO ACTUALLY HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THERE ARE
EQUITY, NOT ALWAYS EQUITY, JUST
RETAIL LICENSES ISSUED. SO WE'VE
ONLY HAD ONE ELIGIBLE
JURISDICTION THUS FAR. PURSUE
THAT. I KNOW IT'S HARD TO
FORECAST THESE THINGS, BUT IF IN
A PERFECT WORLD IS THE SENSE
THAT THE SAME 12 WOULD HAVE COME
OVER INTO PHASE TWO BECAUSE
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
INTEGRATE THOSE, STRATEGY AND TO
BE READY FOR THE NEXT
INSTALLMENT. BUT THE SENSE IS
THAT THE DELAY IN AND WE KNOW
THERE ARE SO MANY BARRIERS AND
DELAYS TO THE RETAIL LICENSING
PROCESS, THE SENSE IS THAT NOW,
AS THE CLOCK CONTINUES, THOSE
BUSINESSES WON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE SUPPORT
IF THESE DOLLARS ARE PULLED BACK
. YEAH. MAKES SENSE. IT DOES. IT
DOES. SO I'D SAY, PHASE ONE
AWARDEES WERE NOT EARMARKED OR
GUARANTEED SINCE IT'S REALLY,
DEPENDENT ON THE NUMBER OF
LICENSES ISSUED. SO IT'S HARD TO
SAY IF WITHIN THE NUMBER OF
YEARS, IF THIS PROPOSAL, WASN'T
BEFORE US, WHETHER THEY WOULD
EVER GET TO PHASE TWO, AND ALL
OF THAT MONEY FROM PHASE ONE IS
STILL GIVEN TO THEM TO SUPPORT
THEM AND EVENTUALLY ISSUING
THOSE RETAIL LICENSES REGARDLESS
IF THEY MADE IT TO PHASE TWO.
AND I'D SAY I THINK OVERALL IT'S
JUST REALLY HARD TO DETERMINE,
YOU KNOW, WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN, ELIGIBLE TO
MAKE IT TO PHASE TWO. SO IT'S
JUST REALLY TOO DIFFICULT TO
SAY. BUT, APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
A POTENTIALLY THEY COULD HAVE
SAY, NO, THEY WON'T BECAUSE
THOSE FUNDS WOULD BE. YEAH.
UNDER THE PROPOSAL, THE GRANT
WILL BE TREATED AS EXHAUSTED.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
WE'LL MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECH ISSUE 23. LET FOLKS GET
FREE SHUFFLED.
AND STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. WE HAVE EVERYBODY UP. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M MARK MUNRO, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND INITIATIVE AT K¾T.
HERE TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
MAP REVISION RELATIVE TO THE
MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND
INITIATIVE. AS I THINK EVERYBODY
IS AWARE, STARTING IN 2021, THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALLOCATED OVER,
THROUGH SEVERAL BUDGETS, A TOTAL
OF $3.873 BILLION TO THE PROJECT
. AND SO, THE, AND HAVING HAVING
LOOKED THROUGH THAT IN THE, IN
THE SUBSEQUENT YEARS, WE HAVE
SIGNED A NUMBER OF CONTRACTS
FOR, PARTNERSHIPS WITH, FOR
LEASES, JOINT BUILDS FOR
PURCHASES, AS WELL AS MOVING
FORWARD WITH, DOING THE WITH
CALTRANS TO PARTNER ON THE
PRE-CONSTRUCTION OF
APPROXIMATELY AS MUCH AS 4000
MILES. SO, AS WE WENT THROUGH A
LOT OF THOSE EFFORTS
SIMULTANEOUSLY, THIS LAST,
JANUARY, WE HAD IDENTIFIED THAT
WE NEEDED A IN ORDER TO GET TO
THE FULL 10,000 PLUS MILES THAT
WE HAD BEEN TARGETING, WE
IDENTIFIED THAT WE WOULD NEED
ANOTHER $1.5 BILLION THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE JANUARY BUDGET.
THAT MAY REVISION REMOVES THAT,
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S HARD
TIMES WITH, YOU KNOW, RELATIVE
TO THE BUDGET AND A LOT OF
DIFFICULT BUDGET DECISIONS HAD
TO BE MADE, ONE OF THOSE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS WAS TO
REMOVE THAT $1.5 BILLION,
HOWEVER, THE, WHILE THAT $1.5
BILLION IS REMOVED, THERE IS
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE INCLUDED SO
THAT, THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
COULD WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE AN INCREASE, AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE HERE, AS AS
NEED IS, IS REEVALUATED. SO
THAT'S HIGH LEVEL WHERE WE'RE
AT. AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT. LEO BRIAN
METZGER. LEO, WE FIND THE
ELIMINATION OF THE PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK ACROSS THE TWO FISCAL
YEARS TO BE REASONABLE, GIVEN
THE SERIOUS BUDGET PROBLEM IN
2425 AND PROJECTED BUDGET
DEFICITS IN FUTURE YEARS.
HOWEVER, WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE REVISED
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
ADMINISTRATION APPROVAL OF AN
ADDITIONAL 1.5 BILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR THE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
IN 2425. AS THERE IS NO FUNDING
SET ASIDE TO SUPPORT THE
AUGMENTATION, THERE IS STILL
INCOMPLETE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
STANDALONE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
THAT WOULD BE FUNDED, AND THERE
IS LIMITED LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
AFFORDED BY WRITTEN NOTIFICATION
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR SUCH A LARGE
REQUEST. INSTEAD, WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVE
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD, AT A MINIMUM,
REQUEST MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION ABOUT THOSE
STANDALONE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
THAT ARE FUNDED BY THE CURRENT
SPENDING PLAN AND ALSO REQUEST A
BUSINESS PLAN FOR THE MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK THAT EXPLAINS HOW
IT WILL BE MAINTAINED AND
OPERATED GOING FORWARD. AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. BRING IT BACK
TO THE SUB. AND TO THAT POINT
THERE, THERE CONTINUES TO BE
SOME FRUSTRATION WITH RESPECT TO
COMPLY SCIENCE AND PROVIDING THE
DETAILED AND TRANSPARENT
INFORMATION. WE HAD A REPORT DUE
MARCH 1ST WHEN THIS PROGRAM
EXPECT PROVIDING THAT
INFORMATION. YEAH NO THANK YOU,
THE SO BACK AS I HAD MENTIONED,
AND STARTING WITH SB 156 AND
SUBSEQUENT, BUDGETS, THE
DEPARTMENT, INCLUDING THE IN ALL
OF THE APPROPRIATIONS THAT WERE
MADE FOR, THE PROJECT HAVE BEEN
A NUMBER OF REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. AND SO, THE WAY
THAT WE HAVE HANDLED THOSE IS TO
BUILD THEM INTO OUR ANNUAL
REPORT. AND SO IN TERMS OF THE
VARIOUS POINTS THAT ARE
MENTIONED IN THE AGENDA, I CAN
POINT COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO WHICH
PAGE OF THE REPORT THOSE ARE
REPORTED ON. I CAN PROVIDE SOME
SUMMARIES, BUT I WENT THROUGH
AGAIN THIS MORNING JUST TO MAKE
SURE EVERYTHING IS THERE. SO,
ONE OF AND I DO WANT TO OFFER AN
APOLOGY BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS WHEN WE MENTION OUR
ANNUAL AND OUR ANNUAL REPORT, WE
TRIED TO CITE THE OTHER THE
VARIOUS PIECES OF LEGISLATION TO
SAY THAT THIS THIS IS INTENDED
TO MEET ALL OF THESE. AND WE DID
NEGLECT TO, TO MENTION AB 102
WHEN WE PUT TOGETHER THE REPORT.
AND SO THE INFORMATION THAT'S
LISTED HERE IS THERE, BUT WE
NEGLECTED TO IDENTIFY IT IN THE
INTRODUCTION. SO, YOU KNOW, I
CERTAINLY WANT TO OFFER AN
APOLOGY, BUT FROM OUR ATTEMPT,
WE'VE PROVIDED THIS INFORMATION.
AND THE ONE PIECE OF INFORMATION
I THINK I WOULD NOTE IS THAT,
THE SECOND TO LAST BULLET TALKS
ABOUT THE ENABLING MIDDLE MILE
FUNDING. AND SO, SOME OF THE
MEMBERS MAY BE TRACKING THAT, IN
2022, THE NTIA MADE $1 BILLION
AVAILABLE FOR ADDITIONAL FUND
FOR FUNDING FOR, MIDDLE MILE
PROJECTS. AND K¾T WAS AWARDED,
LAST YEAR, 73 MILLION. BUT
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T BEGUN TO DRAW
IT DOWN, WE HAVEN'T ENCUMBERED
ANY OF IT. IT WAS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE REPORT. AND SO IN THE
FUTURE, WE WILL INCLUDE THAT,
EVEN IF IT'S, YOU KNOW, ZERO AT
THE TIME, THOUGH, WE DON'T
EXPECT IT TO BE NEXT YEAR. ALL
RIGHT. DO WE DO WE HAVE ANY
CHANGES IN THE DEMAND ESTIMATES
TO COMPLETE? C¢M, WELL, WE
MILEAGE WE DON'T AT THIS TIME,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE THE $1.5 BILLION
REQUEST WAS INTENDED TO GET TO,
WHAT WHAT WAS HAD BROADLY BEEN
OUR GOAL OF THE LARGER 10,000
MILE NETWORK. OUR APPROACH, AT
THIS POINT, GIVEN THE BUDGET,
WILL BE TO, TO LOOK AT OUR
VARIOUS PRIORITIES WHEN WE PUT
TOGETHER THE 10,000 MILE
NETWORK, WE HAD, MADE, MADE IT A
PRIORITY TO GET THROUGH THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO REACH
THOSE, TO REACH THE, UNSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
BY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION, AND, AS WE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE EXISTING
FUNDING, OUR INTENT WITH THAT
WILL BE TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
TOWARDS THOSE PRIORITIES, AND, I
THINK THE, THE BEST TOOL FOR
THAT IS GOING TO BE TARGETING
THE, THE FEDERAL FUNDING ACCOUNT
OR FFA GRANT APPLICATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION,
SOME OF THE MEMBERS MAY BE
TRACKING THAT ALMOST 500
APPLICATIONS WERE RECEIVED, THIS
LAST YEAR FOR, FOR THOSE GRANT
LAST MILE GRANT PROJECTS AND OF
THOSE, 107 HAVE INDICATED THE
INTENT TO SINK TO THE MIDDLE
MILE BROADBAND TO THE MWBE
NETWORK. AND SO I THINK THAT
WOULD BE ONE OF OUR HIGHER
HIGHEST PRIORITIES WOULD BE TO
MAKE SURE THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT, THOSE ARE FUNDED BY THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION,
THAT WE WOULD TARGET OUR
EXISTING RESOURCES TO, TO REACH
THOSE. ALL RIGHT. OTHER OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SO, I
UNDERSTAND THE COMMITMENT AROUND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND IN
OUR HEARING IN APRIL, I THINK IT
WAS OUR SECOND HEARING, I HAD
ASKED FOR DETAILED INFORMATION
THÀNH A LIST ON ALL THE
PRE-CONSTRUCTION, PRIORITIES.
AND I THINK THE CONSULTANTS,
SAID THAT THEY WOULD GET BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE WITH THAT
INFORMATION, INCLUDING THE MOST
UPDATED MAPS, WE HAVE NOT
RECEIVED THAT INFORMATION, AND I
JUST WANT TO REMIND THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD HAD,
THAT CUTS WERE MADE TO THE
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK, THAT WERE
NOT EQUITABLE, WHILE 17% OF THE
STATEWIDE NETWORK WOULD BE CUT,
SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES HELD
ABOUT 77% OF THOSE CUTS. OAKLAND
ANOTHER 56. OF THEIR MIDDLE
MILE. NHIÀU WERE ALSO CUT AT THE
TIME. SO WHAT EXACTLY WHERE
EXACTLY ARE THE INVESTMENTS THAT
YOU ARE PROPOSING HERE BEING
MADE, AND WHEN WILL WE SEE WHAT
AREAS WILL BE PRIORITIZED? YEAH.
SO, NO THANK YOU. LOOK, THE I
THINK THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING ARE RELATIVE TO A
PROPOSAL THAT OR A PLAN THAT CDC
HAD PUT TOGETHER FOR, ABOUT A
YEAR AGO, ALMOST A YEAR AGO, AND
WE HAD AT THE TIME NOT HAD THE
AS THE INFORMATION THAT WE NOW
HAVE IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
REACH, SOME OF THE SPECIFIC,
MORE SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE FFA
GRANT LOCATIONS OR FFA GRANT
PROGRAM. SO WE WILL, I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE A MAJOR
DIFFERENCE IN OUR APPROACH IS
REALLY BEING ABLE TO TARGET SOME
OF THOSE AREAS, RELATIVE TO SOME
OF THE AREAS THAT YOU MENTIONED
AND SPECIFICALLY IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA, AND I THINK,
DIRECTOR BARRY CRIMMINS HAD
NOTED, LAST TIME THAT THERE WERE
WHEN WE PUT TOGETHER THE MAP,
THERE WAS A, THERE WAS A
TECHNICAL AREA WHERE A PROBLEM
SPECIFICALLY IN THAT AREA WHERE
SOME OF THE CALTRANS
CONSTRUCTION HAD BEEN LEFT OFF
OF THE MAP. AND SO THERE WAS
INITIAL REACTION ON VERY
UNDERSTANDABLY FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE, THOSE ARE SOME SOME OF
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE, AND WE
CERTAINLY DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE
THOSE OFF. AND SO THOSE HAD BEEN
ADDED BACK, IN TERMS OF UPDATED
MAPS, WE THE MAP, THE MOST UP TO
DATE MAP IS THE ONE THAT'S ON
OUR WEBSITE. AND THAT IS STILL
THAT STILL REFLECTS THE FACT
THAT IT STILL REFLECTS THE
10,000 PLUS MILES THAT WE HAVE
BEEN MOVING FORWARD WITH UP
UNTIL THIS POINT, NOW THAT, YOU
KNOW, ASSUMING THAT WE WON'T BE
GETTING THE $1.5 BILLION, WE
WILL HAVE TO GO BACK AND DO SOME
AND REEVALUATE THAT. WE'LL HAVE
TO GO BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT 10,000 MILES AND SEE HOW WE
HOW WE ALLOCATE THOSE FUNDS. AND
AGAIN, IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
OUR, OUR GOAL TO BE ABLE TO GET
TO THOSE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES, WE THINK WITHIN
EXISTING FUNDING, WE WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC WE CAN GET TO MOST OF
THEM. WE'RE OPTIMISTIC WE CAN
GET TO MOST OR ALL OF THE FFA
GRANT FUNDED LOCATIONS. BUT
THAT'S ANALYSIS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO DO NOW, NOW THAT WE
ARE NO LONGER EXPECTING THE
FUNDING. AND SO AND ONE OTHER
ONE OTHER POINT I'LL MAKE IS
THAT, IN TERMS OF WHERE OUR, IN
TERMS OF CALTRANS PROGRESS IN
MOVING, MOVING SECTIONS FORWARD
TO PRE-CONSTRUCTION, THEY
PROVIDE AN UPDATE AND I THINK
PROVIDED AN UPDATED VERSION FOR,
FOR STAFF, BUT THEY PROVIDE
UPDATES AT THE MIDDLE MILE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF MILES IN
EACH REGION BY QUARTER THAT THEY
WOULD PLAN TO HAVE READY, BUT
ONE OF THE PIECES OF INFORMATION
THAT IS STILL BEING, ADDRESSED
IS THAT WE WENT OUT WITH ANOTHER
SOLICITATION FOR THE SO-CALLED
RFI SQUARED, WHERE WE GO OUT TO
LOOK FOR ADDITIONAL PARTNERS TO
DO JOINT BUILDS AND LEASES. WE
FOUND THAT THE FIRST TIME WE DID
THAT, WE WERE ABLE TO BECAUSE
WE'RE ABLE TO SHARE THE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS, WE WERE ABLE
TO GET MANY MORE MILES, BECAUSE
THE COSTS WERE REDUCED. AND TO A
LARGE EXTENT, WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE LEASED AREAS,
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE, SERVICE WELL BEFORE THE
20TH DECEMBER 2026 DEADLINE. SO
THERE'S SOME REAL BENEFITS TO
CONTINUE TO PURSUE THOSE. SO WE
WENT OUT FOR ANOTHER ONE OF
THOSE, AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
EVALUATING APPROXIMATELY 50
PROPOSALS. SO THAT WILL ALSO
CHANGE. AND, DEPENDING ON WHAT
WE'RE ABLE TO FIND THERE, WHAT
WE'RE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE AND
AGREE TO THERE THAT WILL ALSO
CHANGE. AND, THE WHERE CALTRANS
WILL BE DOING ITS CONSTRUCTION,
SO ALL OF THIS NEW INFORMATION,
IT CONTINUES TO PROVIDE UPDATES,
BUT WE DON'T HAVE AT THIS TIME,
I KNOW CALTRANS DOES ITS
ESTIMATES BASED LARGELY, AND IT
MODELS IT OUT. AND CALTRANS, I
MEAN, THEY BUILD PROJECTS. I
WOULD SAY THEY'RE THEY'RE FAIRLY
THEY'RE PRETTY ACCURATE. THEY'RE
PRETTY GOOD AT MODELING THESE
THINGS OUT. BUT IT'S NOT THE
SAME THING AS, HAVING SPECIFIC
MILES THAT ARE DECIDED. IN OTHER
WORDS, THE SECOND QUARTER, WE'RE
GOING TO BE DONE. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THIS SEGMENT DONE, OR AND
THE THIRD QUARTER ARE GOING TO
HAVE THIS SEGMENT DONE. AND SO
THAT'S WHERE, THEY'RE CONTINUING
TO WORK ON ALL TEN OR ALL 4000
MILES CURRENTLY WHILE WE'RE
CONTINUING TO EXPLORE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE FOR THOSE
RFI SQUARED DEALS. SO I'M HOPING
THAT, IN THE NEXT MAC MEETING
IS, I BELIEVE, JULY 19TH,
FRIDAY, JULY 19TH, I WOULD LOVE
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT BY THEN
WE'D BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE. I
EXPECT TO HAVE MORE INFORMATION.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO SAY
WE'D HAVE BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
REVISED INFORMATION AT THAT
POINT. BUT WE'RE AGAIN, WE'RE IN
NEGOTIATIONS, AND SO WE'LL HAVE
TO SEE WHERE WE'RE AT. BUT
THAT'S I WILL SAY, IS THAT IN
TERMS OF THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
THUS FAR, WHAT'S ON OUR WEBSITE
IS AS UP TO DATE AS WE HAVE. SO
YOU'RE SAYING AFTER THIS, AFTER
THE BUDGET IS SAID AND DONE,
THEN WE'LL KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE EITHER IN
THE CALTRANS PROJECTS ARE PART
OF THAT LAST MILE PRIORITIZATION
OR PART OF ALL OF THE COLLIDING,
FACTORS THAT YOU JUST SORT OF
LAID OUT, BUT WE WON'T HAVE.
YOU'RE SAYING THE DETAIL ON
WHETHER OR NOT AND FOR ME
PERSONALLY, VÆ IN MY DISTRICT,
WHICH WAS THE COMMUNITY THAT WAS
LEFT OUT, WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION CONFIRMED WOULD
BE PRIORITIZED IN THIS ROUND OF
BUDGETS. YOU'RE SAYING WE WON'T
KNOW IF THAT IS THE CASE UNTIL
AFTER THE BUDGET IS ESSENTIALLY
ADOPTED? AND THEN IT'S A WAIT
AND SEE. MAYBE YES. I MEAN,
THAT'S UNFORTUNATELY I THINK
THAT THAT'S PARTLY THE CASE.
IT'S STILL OUR INTENT TO BE ABLE
TO GET TO THOSE AREAS. THAT'S I
MEAN, THOSE ARE, YOU KNOW, SOME
OF THE HIGHEST PRIORITY AREAS IN
THE STATE. BUT I, I, WE'RE NOT
IN A PLACE YET WHERE WE CAN SAY
EXACTLY WITH THE REDUCED
FUNDING, HOW WE'RE HOW THAT'S
GOING TO LOOK THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND WILL WORK AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN TO GET THAT
INFORMATION AND WHAT TIME FRAME
BEFORE OUR DEADLINE TO ADOPT
THIS BUDGET, CAN WE EXPECT
DETAILED INFORMATION ON ON ALL
OF THE COMPETING FACTORS THAT
YOU LAID OUT THAT GIVES US A
MORE EXACT PICTURE OF WHAT
PROJECTS WILL BE PRIORITIZED AND
IN WHAT AREAS, WHEN IT COMES TO
THE NEGOTIATIONS, I THINK WE
WERE, HOPING TO BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THOSE IN JULY, BY JULY
AND AUGUST, IT'S A LITTLE FASTER
THAN WE WERE ABLE TO DO IT LAST
TIME, BUT THAT'S GOING TO BE, A
LARGE DETERMINING FACTOR IN
TERMS OF WHAT WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO
GET, WHERE THOSE END UP BEING
AND THEN WHERE WE'RE ABLE TO, TO
BUILD AFTER THAT. SO I DON'T
ANTICIPATE HAVING MOST OF THOSE,
YOU KNOW, REACHED A DEFINITIVE
POINT. WE'RE ABLE TO SIGN
AGREEMENTS, BEFORE JULY. WELL,
IF WE WON'T SEE A MAP THAT
SHOWS, AT LEAST IN LOS ANGELES,
WHERE THE MIDDLE MILE,
INVESTMENTS WILL HAPPEN, IT WILL
, BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME,
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO GO ABOUT WHAT I WANT TO
SAY IS DAILY LIFE. YOU CANNOT
NOT DO YOUR HOMEWORK. YOU CANNOT
APPLY FOR JOBS. YOU CANNOT GET
MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS, YOU CANNOT
DO ALL OF THE THINGS THAT NOW
THE INTERNET, IS REQUIRED TO DO,
BECAUSE THOSE COMMITMENTS THAT
WERE MADE ARE BEING BROKEN AND
THERE'S NOT A CLEAR SNAPSHOT IN
TERMS OF, HOW WE ARE PUTTING OUR
INVESTMENTS WHERE OUR WORDS WERE
, WHICH WAS THAT THESE AREAS
THAT WERE LEFT OUT IN THE LAST
ROUND WOULD BE PRIORITIZED IN
THIS ROUND. BUT NOW WE'RE SAYING
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CLEAR MAP OR
PICTURE OR, CLARITY THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES WILL, IN FACT,
RECEIVE THE, THE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED. THAT IS AN
UNACCEPTABLE RESPONSE, GIVEN HOW
MANY TIMES WE HAVE DISCUSSED
THIS, THIS ISSUE, I THINK IN THE
LAST I THINK THE LA TIMES REPORT
WE TALKED ABOUT IN OUR LAST
HEARING, COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
BEVERLY HILLS, WERE PRIORITIZED
OVER SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES.
AND IT'S A SITUATION WHERE WE
ARE PUTTING WHAT IS THE MOST,
EXPEDIENT TO DO OVER WHAT IS THE
MORALLY RIGHT THING TO DO, WHICH
IS COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE NO
INFRASTRUCTURE AND NO SERVICE,
AGAIN, ARE LEFT ON THE CUTTING
ROOM FLOOR BECAUSE IT'S EASIER
TO ADD ON TO COMMUNITIES THAT
ALREADY HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
THIS SORT OF LAYOUT OF
INFORMATION PROVIDED TODAY JUST
REINFORCES THAT THIS HAS NOT
BEEN AN EQUITABLE PROCESS. THIS
HAS NOT BEEN A FAIR PROCESS. AND
AGAIN, OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING LEFT
BEHIND. AND THESE WERE THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE OUR CHILDREN
WERE HAVING TO DO HOMEWORK AT A
NEIGHBORING MCDONALD'S BECAUSE
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS DON'T HAVE
INTERNET. AND HERE WE ARE, 2019,
20, 2022, 23, 24. WE ARE SAYING
THEY STILL WON'T AND WON'T
CONTINUE TO HAVE IT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T PROVIDE AN EXACT TIME
FRAME WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY SEE
THAT THESE COMMUNITIES ARE
PRIORITIZED. IT IS, IT IS
DISAPPOINTING TO HEAR AND I, I
HOPE THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO EXPEDITE, GIVEN ALL THE
GREAT WORK THAT IS HAPPENING
WITH CALTRANS, ALL OF THE
FEDERAL APPLICATION REVIEWS THAT
WE CAN SETTLE ON IDENTIFYING
WHAT COMMUNITIES RS WILL BE
TOUCHED BY THESE PRECIOUS
RESOURCES THAT WE WILL NEED TO
EXPEND IN THIS BUDGET. WE HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISION ON HOW WE INVEST THOSE
FUNDS AND THAT THOSE HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES ARE PRIORITIZED. AND
THE CHAIR WILL STRONGLY
ASSOCIATE HIMSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS FROM THE SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES. THIS TO SOME DEGREE
GREATLY UNACCEPTABLE AND
DISAPPOINTING, AND WE NEED TO DO
BETTER, AND I DO QUESTION THE
METHODOLOGY THAT WE'VE USED AS
TO HOW WE END UP PRIORITIZING
IT. AND IT CAN'T BE DONE JUST
FROM AN ENGINEERING PERSPECTIVE
THAT SENATOR. NHIÀU WITH REGARD
TO THAT POINT, IF I UNDERSTAND
CORRECTLY, YOU'RE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRUST THE FACT
THAT YOU'LL HAVE THIS
INFORMATION AFTER THE BUDGET IS
ADOPTED AND TRUST IS FINE. BUT
IN THE WORDS OF A FORMER
PRESIDENT, TRUST BUT VERIFY, AS
REGARDING A PREVIOUS POINT, DID
I HEAR YOU TO SAY THAT THE
REPORT AS REPORT BACK AS
REQUIRED BY AB 102, YOU HAVE
DONE? YES. SO WE, SB 156
REQUIRES, K¾T TO DO AN ANNUAL
REPORT. AND SO, AND THEN
SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION IS ADDED
IN ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. SO WE BUILD ALL OF
THAT INTO OUR ANNUAL REPORT SO
THAT WE DON'T END UP SPENDING A
LOT OF TIME DOING. I DON'T THINK
WE'VE SEEN IT. IT'S IT WAS
RELEASED, I'M SORRY, IT WAS
RELEASED IN APRIL. WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO REACH OUT AND GIVE YOU
THE LINK. BUT IT WAS RELEASED
RELEASED TO THE, I BELIEVE TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IN APRIL, AND SO IT'S
CERTAINLY OUT THERE AND WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE A LINK TO YOUR
OFFICE, THAT'D BE GREAT. I HAVE
NOT SEEN IT. AND SO WITHOUT
DOUBT, WITHOUT DIGESTING THAT
INFORMATION AND WITH REGARD TO
THE PREVIOUS QUESTIONS, I DON'T
SEE HOW IT MAKES SENSE TO
UNCONDITIONALLY DELEGATE IT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE DRAW
ON THESE FUNDS. SO THAT KIND OF
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME.
SENATOR, ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? THANK YOU. THIS ITEM
IS HELD OPEN. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES. ISSUE 24 CAPITAL
REPAIRS, FUNDING REDUCTION FROM
THE MAY REVISION
.
AND STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD. AND PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. NATALIE GRISWOLD,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES REDUCING THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION BY
ABOUT 7.1 MILLION. GENERAL FUND
IN 20 2425 AND 20 2526 DGS
RECEIVES AN ANNUAL APPROPRIATION
FOR CAPITAL REPAIRS. USE OF THIS
FUNDING IS GENERALLY DIRECTED BY
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE OF THE
LEGISLATURE. SINCE THE CAPITOL
ANNEX IS CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSTRUCTION, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES PAUSING THIS FUNDING
FOR TWO FISCAL YEARS TO ADDRESS
THE GENERAL FUND DEFICIT. HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT, LEO, NO COMMENT. ALL
RIGHT. TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
OPERATIONAL IMPACTS OF ANY KIND.
SO CURRENTLY THIS FUNDING IS
DIRECTED GENERALLY BY JOINT
RULES. THERE'S CURRENTLY SOME
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR PROJECTS
THAT ARE ONGOING, BUT ULTIMATELY
IT WOULD BE UP TO THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE HAS PURVIEW TO
DIRECT THE USE OF THIS FUNDING.
ALL RIGHT. SENATOR, SO, I'M
APPRECIATING THIS. DO YOU HAVE
ANY INFORMATION ON ON, THE
PROGRESS OF THE, THE REPAIRS AND
PARTICULARLY IN TERMS OF, EQUITY
RELATED TO THAT? THERE'S BEEN
CONCERNS ABOUT, AS WE ARE
INVESTING IN MAKING OUR CAPITAL
REPAIRS, THAT WE DON'T HAVE
EVIDENCE THAT THAT
UNDERREPRESENTED POPULATIONS ARE
BEING INVITED TO PARTICIPATE IN
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES, BE IT THE
LARGE SCALE CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
OR SOME OF THE, THE, YOU KNOW,
LESS RESOURCE INTENSIVE
IMPROVEMENTS. CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
HOW ACCESSIBLE THE WORKFORCE IS
TO, TO ENGAGING AND
PARTICIPATING IN THESE DOLLARS?
AND I'M PARTICULARLY THINKING
ABOUT WOMEN AND BLACK WORKERS,
ETC. GOOD MORNING, HEATHER
CARLSON. I'M THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER FOR DGS. GENERALLY
SPEAKING, THIS MONEY IS HELD IN
OUR ARCHITECTURAL REVOLVING
FUND. BUT THE INDIVIDUAL
CONTRACTS FOR THE USAGE IS DONE
THROUGH THROUGH THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE. SO WE DON'T ACTUALLY
HOLD THE CONTRACTS. HAVING SAID
THAT, I WOULD SAY THAT IT IS A
PRIORITY OF DGS, AND WE HAVE
SMALL BUSINESS, DISABLED
VETERANS, QUOTAS THAT WE TRY TO
USE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IN
SELECTING CONTRACTORS THAT WE
URGE ALL STATE AGENCIES. WE HAVE
KIND OF A LIMIT OF HOW MUCH THAT
WE WANT TO SEE GO TO THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES, DISABLED VETERANS,
THOSE KINDS OF VENDORS. CAN YOU
GIVE ME A STATISTIC ON WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE CONTRACTS ARE
HELD BY THOSE? GROUPS, STATEWIDE
OR SPECIFIC TO THIS PROGRAM?
BOTH, I DON'T HAVE THOSE AT MY
FINGERTIPS, BUT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE THAT BACK AND GET BACK TO
YOU. IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO SEE
IT. ONE OF THE THINGS WHEN I WAS
PART OF A BILL, SB 150, WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE NEED TO
ENSURE STRONG LABOR STANDARDS,
WHICH I KNOW THE STATE DOES HAVE
IN TERMS OF ITS, CAPITAL
PROJECTS, BUT ALSO THAT THERE
ARE COMMUNITY BENEFITS WITHIN
THOSE AND BY COMMUNITY BENEFITS,
WE'RE MEANING THAT THERE IS A
FAIR ACCESS AND PARTICIPATION,
PARTICULARLY OF UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES, DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES, UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES IN PUBLIC CAPITAL
AND INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. SO
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO SEE HOW THE
STATE IS FARING IN TERMS OF OUR
OWN CAPITAL REPAIRS. IN THAT
REGARD, I'LL HAPPY TO GET THAT
INFORMATION FOR YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM?
IF NOT, THIS ITEM IS HELD OPEN.
ISSUE 25 NET ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION FUNDING REDUCTION.
PLEASE PROCEED. NATALIE
GRISWOLD, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO
REVERT $2.5 MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN 20 2324 AND REDUCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION BY
2.5 MILLION IN 20 2425 AND 20
2526. THIS LIMITED TERM FUNDING
WAS ORIGINALLY APPROPRIATED IN
THE 2023 BUDGET ACT TO IMPLEMENT
CHAPTER THREE, SIX, EIGHT
STATUTES OF 2022, ALSO KNOWN AS
SB 1203, WHICH REQUIRES NET ZERO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN
STATE AGENCY OPERATIONS BY 2035.
THIS CURRENT YEAR REVERSION AND
OUTYEAR REDUCTION IS PROPOSED TO
ADDRESS THE GENERAL FUND
DEFICIT. HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY. ALL RIGHT. TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE THAT ITEM
IS HELD OPEN. AND TAKE US TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF SHOWBIZ
ARTS COUNCIL ISSUE 26.
AND PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME FOR
THE RECORD AND PROCEED WHEN
READY. ALSO, SAU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WILL GO THE ARTS COUNCIL
REDUCTION FIRST. THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES A $10 MILLION
ONGOING REDUCTION TO THE ARTS
GRANTS ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL, THE
BASELINE BUDGET TO SUPPORT THESE
GRANTS TOTALS $24.3 MILLION.
THIS IS A REDUCTION OF $10
MILLION TO THAT ALLOCATION,
BRINGING THE TOTAL AMOUNT FOR
ALLOCATION TO BE ALLOCATED BY
THE ARTS COUNCIL TO $14.3
MILLION. ONGOING THESE ARE FUNDS
THAT ARE ADMINISTERED BY THE
COUNCIL THAT HOLDS VOTES EACH
YEAR. TO DETERMINE HOW THESE
GRANTS ARE ALLOCATED. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU LEO. ALL RIGHT. TO THE
SUB SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
JUST WANTED TO KNOW, CAN YOU
GIVE US SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT
TYPES OF GRANTS HAVE BEEN,
AWARDED AND FUNDED THROUGH THE
PROGRAM? YES. HI, I'M IOANNA Kò.
I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL. AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. THE
GRANT, THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL HAS BEEN AROUND SINCE
ALMOST 50 YEARS. WE'VE SERVED AS
A CATALYST AGENCY TO FOSTER
CULTURAL VIBRANCY AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT, PROMOTE ACCESS,
EQUITY AND DIVERSITY, AND INVEST
IN ARTS EDUCATION THROUGH GRANT
PROGRAMS, SERVICES AND STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIP SHIPS. WE SUPPORT
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS AND CONTENT
DEVELOPMENT, AND OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS ARE VARIED. WE HAVE
GENERAL OPERATING GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT WE INVEST A LOT IN ALMOST
$10 MILLION EVERY YEAR. WE ALSO
HAVE PROJECT BASED GRANTS,
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DEVELOPED WITH
AN EQUITY LENS. WE WORK WE HAVE
A STRATEGIC FRAMEWORK THAT IS
BASED IN EQUITY. SO WE HAVE
PROJECT BASED GRANTS FOR ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE INTENDED
TO SERVE THE COMMUNITIES
DEVELOPED BY THE COMMUNITIES.
AND, EMBRACING CREATIVITY TO
HAVE THE COMMUNITIES THRIVE. AND
HOW MANY GRANTS WERE AWARDED? WE
HAVE ABOUT 870 GRANTS THAT ARE
AWARDED ANNUALLY WITH THE
BUDGET. WITH THIS REDUCTION, WE
WILL SEE ABOUT $4 MILLION GO OUT
THE DOOR NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM? ALL
RIGHT. ISSUES HELD OPEN. BIGGEST
ISSUE 27 TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO MOVE THE ARTS COUNCIL TO
GO-BIZ. PLEASE PROCEED. THE MAY
REVISION ESTABLISHES THE SIR
CHARLES SAU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE MAY REVISION
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THERE. THIS IS A NET
ZERO ADJUSTMENT OF RESOURCES AS
WELL AS STATUTORY CHANGES TO
EFFECTUATE THIS TRANSITION.
OVERALL, THIS TRANSITION WILL
ALLOW FOR GREATER EFFICIENCY IN
STATE GOVERNMENT, AS GÓMEZ AND
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL SHARE
COMMON GOALS AROUND PROMOTING
ARTS AND CULTURE THROUGH THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY. WORKING GROUP,
VISIT CALIFORNIA AND THE OFFICE
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE.
THIS PARTNERSHIP WILL CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BROADER
ENGAGEMENT BETWEEN THE EXPERTISE
OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
AND THE CULTURAL SECTOR, AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF GÓMEZ AND ECONOMIC
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
FURTHER, THIS REORGANIZATION
WILL ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL TO LEVERAGE GÓMEZ
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
CAPACITIES. THIS WILL IMPROVE
THE ARTS COUNCIL'S GENERAL
OPERATIONS. THIS PROPOSAL WILL
NOT DISRUPT ANY OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS PROGRAMING OR
ACTIVITIES, AND WILL PROVIDE
INCREASED OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES, ESPECIALLY WITHIN
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE GRANT
MAKING PROCESS. ADDITIONALLY,
THIS TRAILER BILL EXTENDS THE
SUNSET FOR THE KEEP ARTS AND
SCHOOLS TAX CHECK SEVEN YEARS,
UNTIL 2032. THIS THE REVENUES
FROM THIS PROGRAM SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE K THROUGH
12 ARTS PROGRAMS. I THANK YOU LÀ
JARED SIPPEL. WITH THE LAO. WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL WITHOUT PREJUDICE. THE
PROPOSAL COULD MERIT
CONSIDERATION IF IT RESULTED IN
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS TO HELP
ADDRESS THE STATE'S BUDGET
PROBLEM. HOWEVER, GIVEN THAT NO
SAVINGS ARE BEING PROPOSED, WE
FIND LITTLE REASON FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THIS
PROPOSAL UNDER THE COMPRESSED
TIME FRAMES THAT MAY REVISION,
WE BELIEVE THAT SUCH A PROPOSAL
WARRANTS GREATER SCRUTINY FROM
THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH EITHER
THE POLICY PROCESS OR EARLIER ON
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS. THIS
WOULD GIVE THE LEGISLATURE TIME
TO ASK QUESTIONS, OBTAIN INPUT
FROM STAKEHOLDERS IN THE PUBLIC,
AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT ANY
SAVINGS FROM OPERATIONAL ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICIENCIES ARE
IDENTIFIED. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SMALL CHÁVEZ,
I JUST HAD A QUESTION IN TERMS
OF THIS TRANSITION, AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S, ALL THE
PROGRAM IS MOVING OVER. DOES
THAT INCLUDE THE STAFFING THE
WORKERS, AND WILL THEY HOW MANY
STAFF ARE WE TALKING ABOUT? AND
WILL THEY ALL TRANSITION? THIS
IS NOT ELIMINATING ANY POSITIONS
. THAT IS CHARLES SAU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THAT IS CORRECT.
THIS ROLE DOES NOT ELIMINATE ANY
POSITIONS. CURRENTLY, THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL IS
APPROVED FOR 24.4 AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS. ALL POSITIONS WILL BE
TRANSITIONED TO GO-BIZ. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE STAFF? I TAKE
THE LOSS INPUT. IF NOT, THAT
ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND WORK. THAT
WILL BRING US TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION OF THE DOCKET.
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYONE
TO ADDRESS THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON A
MATTER ON THE AGENDA, AND WE'LL
TAKE A MINUTE TO GET FOLKS,
RESET.
IS THIS LOOK RIGHT? STILL THE
GROUPINGS? ANY CHANGES TO THE
GROUPINGS? OH, YEAH. THAT'S IT.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, SIR. GREAT
ONE AND THREE. YES BECAUSE THIS
IS FROM YOUR UPDATED. THIS WAS
THE LATEST VERSION YOU SENT ME
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON. THIS IS THE
SCRIPT FROM FIVE, 7:00 LAST
NIGHT. SO HE'S CHANGED. IT HAS.
OKAY. SO THESE THESE ARE THE
ONES. YEP. ALL RIGHT. GOOD. GO.
THANK YOU FOR. QUITE, QUITE. THE
CREW HERE. ALL RIGHT. IF WE CAN
KIND OF MAINTAIN ORDER, WE TRY
TO ORGANIZE OURSELVES IN LINE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR INPUT. WE KNOW YOU HAVE A
LOT OF IT. IT'S VALUABLE, WHEN
YOU. WHEN I RECOGNIZE YOU,
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD AND TRY TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENT TO ONE MINUTE. WELCOME
LIFE. LET'S CHECK SERGEANTS,
CHECK THAT AUDIO FOR ME. JUST
GIVE US JUST A MOMENT, OKAY?
OKAY. AM I LIVE NOW? YOU ARE.
HEY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR PADILLA. SENATOR NHÀ
NHIÀU. WHY AM I SAYING THAT?
THAT WAY? I'M CORRECTING
EVERYBODY HOW TO PRONOUNCE YOUR
NAME. AND THANK YOU, SENATOR,
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS FOR, THIS
HEARING TODAY. AND SO I'M LORI
KAMMERER, I'M REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS, CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER, AND I WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE HAVE 2000, 17
LETTERS THAT ARE SITTING RIGHT
HERE THAT ARE FROM ALL DIFFERENT
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO ARE OPPOSED
TO CUTTING THE FUNDING FOR THE
TAP, THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS, WE HAVE
BROUGHT SMALL BUSINESSES FROM
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA TO
SACRAMENTO TODAY, SO THAT YOU
CAN HEAR THEIR STORIES AND HOW
IMPORTANT THE SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS ARE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. I HAVE LETTERS FROM
ALL OF YOUR DISTRICTS, HUNDREDS
OF LETTERS FROM SMALL BUSINESSES
WHO HAVE BENEFITED, BENEFITED
WITH THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND TRAINING, IN WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESSES. THE CUTS THAT ARE
PROPOSED WOULD BASICALLY GO FROM
26 MILLION, TO 13 MILLION,
CUTTING HALF OF THE FUNDING OF
THE PROGRAM, WHICH MEANS THAT
HALF OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES
WOULD RECEIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. HALF OF YOUR
DISTRICTS WOULD RECEIVE, I
SHOULD SAY YOU'D BE CUT IN HALF,
AS FAR AS THE AMOUNT OF JOBS
THAT WOULD BE CREATED AS WELL AS
THE FUNDING THAT WOULD BE COMING
IN TERMS OF, TAX REVENUE AND
EVERYTHING FROM THESE SMALL
BUSINESS STARTING UP. SO THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
, I WILL BE SHARING LETTERS WITH
THE COMMITTEE STAFF, BUT THERE'S
TOO MANY HERE TO BRING UP. AND
SO, FEEL FREE TO LOOK THROUGH
THESE. THERE'S A REPRESENTATIVES
SMALL BUSINESSES, FROM ALL OF
YOUR DISTRICTS IN THESE LETTERS.
SO THANK YOU. WE URGE AND
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DEANNA
HEARN. I'M A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER IN SOLANO COUNTY, THE NAME
OF MY COMPANY IS MIRACLE MATH
COACHING. WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOR
16 YEARS AND WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
AROUND THAT LONG WITHOUT, TAP, I
DO REALIZE THAT YOU GUYS HAVE A
REALLY BIG, DECISIONS TO, TO
MAKE, BUT THE THING THAT I
REALLY WANT TO ADMONISH YOU IS
THAT, THE TIME THAT WE'RE IN
RIGHT NOW, ESPECIALLY WITH AI
AND TECHNOLOGY, THESE FUNDS ARE
CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE THAT SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS LIKE MYSELF,
UNDERSERVED FIRST GENERATION
STUDENT, WENT INTO DATA SCIENCE,
CAME OUT OF THAT INTO THE FIELD
OF ENTREPRENEURSHIP, DID NOT
KNOW ANYTHING, AND THIS PROGRAM
HAS REALLY CHANGED MY BUSINESS.
I EMPLOY 15 DIFFERENT
INSTRUCTORS. WE GO INTO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO TRANSFORM EDUCATION,
HELPING STUDENTS TO CLOSE GAPS
THREE TIMES AT THE RATE OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS USING BRAIN
BASED LEARNING. AND SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. AND I WOULD
NOT BE WHERE I AM TODAY WITHOUT
THIS PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
SENATOR PADILLA. SENATOR NILO,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, MY
NAME IS DANNY FITZGERALD. I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR BUSINESS ADVANCEMENT
AT SOUTHWESTERN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN CHULA VISTA, I
OVERSEE THE SMALL BUSINESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS THAT
INCLUDES THE SBDC, THE WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTER, AND OUR
PROCUREMENT ASSISTANCE CENTER
THAT SERVES SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES, WE SERVE
WELL. WE SERVE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES THAT
REPRESENT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
JOBS. THE TYPES OF SERVICE WE
PROVIDE, IN ADDITION TO,
OBVIOUSLY, CAPITAL ACCESS, BUT
ALSO WITH BUSINESS STARTS, BUT
ALSO IN PARTICULAR FOR
PROCUREMENT ASSISTANCE AS WELL.
WE HELP COMPANIES ACCESS OVER
$400 MILLION WORTH OF CONTRACTS.
THESE ARE NEW, DIVERSE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THESE. THESE ARE
BUSINESSES LIKE IMPERIAL PIPE
AND SUPPLY THAT ARE WORKING ON
LITHIUM VALLEY TODAY. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE ARE THE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE LOCAL
BUSINESSES, NOT JUST BUSINESSES
THAT ARE COMING INTO AREAS LIKE
IMPERIAL VALLEY, BUT THE LOCAL
FOLKS THAT ARE ABLE TO OWN THE
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS HIRE FOLKS
FROM THAT AREA. IT'S ALSO
BUSINESSES LIKE WEPA
CONSTRUCTION, WHICH IS A VETERAN
OWNED, DIVERSE BUSINESS THAT'S
DOING GOVERNMENT CONTRACTING
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION. THEY HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY GROWN NOW,
EMPLOYING EMPLOYING WELL OVER 50
PEOPLE, REALLY BEING ABLE TO
CREATE THAT TYPE OF ECONOMIC
IMPACT. AND SO THESE TYPES OF
CUTS WOULD REQUIRE ME TO
PROBABLY CUT DOWN MY STAFF OF
120 ADVISORS AND CONSULTANTS IN
HALF, RESULTING IN SERVICES THAT
WERE GOING TO BE SEVERELY
RESTRICTED. THESE BUSINESSES ARE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THAT TYPE OF ASSISTANCE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND AGAIN, AS A
COURTESY, WE WELCOME YOUR INPUT.
BUT PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
TO ONE MINUTE. THANK YOU. NHîNG
CHEN, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, MY
NAME IS SONYA MORALES. I AM A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER. AND I
OPERATE A COMPANY CALLED DIRT
NURSES, WHICH IS A COMMERCIAL
JANITORIAL. SERVICE IN STOCKTON,
CALIFORNIA. I RECENTLY JUST GOT
CERTIFIED THROUGH THE PROGRAM, I
RECENTLY JUST, RECEIVED A AWARD
BID IN THE PORT OF STOCKTON. I'M
ALSO GOING UP FOR ANOTHER BID IN
JUNE, THIS PROGRAM HAS OPENED MY
EYES TO, OPPORTUNITIES THAT I
NEVER EVEN KNEW EXISTED, AND MY
BUSINESS IS STARTING TO GROW,
AND I SEE THAT. AND WITHOUT THIS
PROGRAM, I WOULD HAVE NEVER
KNOWN ALL THESE OPPORTUNITIES
WERE OUT THERE. SO I JUST WANTED
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS SOCHI
PEREZ. I'M A MARINE CORPS
VETERAN, 100% DISABLED, AND I
OWN A BRICK AND MORTAR IN LODI,
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO HAVE A
CONSULTING FIRM, AND I'D LIKE TO
SAY THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES, POST COVID IS
ACTUALLY KEEPING MY DOORS OPEN,
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY WAS THE
LONGEST COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR 58 COUNTIES THAT
KEPT MY BUSINESS CLOSED. THAT
MEANT I LOST 19 OF MY EMPLOYEES.
MY TRAINERS WERE GONE, SO BEING
ABLE TO PAY MY RENT $9,000 A
MONTH OUT OF POCKET WITHOUT
HAVING GYM MEMBERSHIP OR ANY
TYPE OF RESOURCES BECAUSE I DID
NOT QUALIFY FOR ANY OF THE
FUNDING THAT WENT THROUGH GÓMEZ
BECAUSE I DID NOT HAVE A NET
REVENUE. SO POST COVID, ALL OF
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE BEING
SET, I DO NOT MEAN I HAVE TO
SUPPLEMENT TO KEEP MY BRICK AND
MORTAR OPEN BY CONSULTING AND
HAVING FEDERAL CONTRACTS, BUT A
LOT OF THE RESOURCES AND THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT I'VE GAINED HAS
BEEN BECAUSE OF SBDC, THE
ABILITY TO CERTIFY THE ABILITY
TO MAINTAIN THAT IS ALL
KNOWLEDGE BASE THAT HAS BEEN
GAINED THROUGH SBDC. THOSE
RESOURCES ARE NOT AVAILABLE
ANYWHERE ELSE. TO CUT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT IS SIGNIFICANT, BUT
FOR ME RIGHT NOW, I STILL HAVE
TO KEEP MY DOORS OPEN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
. MY NAME IS KRISTEN JOHNSON.
I'M DIRECTOR OF SMALL BUSINESS
PROGRAMS FOR THE RESEARCH ARM OF
HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY, NOW
CALLED CAL POLY. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S 50% CUT TO
TAP. AND I WANT TO MAKE THE
POINT THAT SSBCI FUNDS DO NOT
REPLACE TAP. THEY ARE DIFFERENT
CLIENTS AT DIFFERENT STAGES OF
BUSINESS THAN THE SSBCI, AND
THEY PAY FOR DIFFERENT THINGS.
IN FACT, WITHOUT TAP FUNDING, IT
WILL BE NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
FULFILL ON THE SSBCI PROGRAM
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF BUSINESSES WE'RE
WORKING WITH, I'VE PERSONALLY
SEEN THE TRANSFORMATION THAT
THIS FUNDING SUPPORTS. YOU'VE
RECEIVED OVER 2000 LETTERS FROM
58 COUNTIES. WE ASK YOU TO STAND
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES AND REJECT
THE BUDGET CUT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
KIRK CLARK. I'M THE REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER PROGRAM. AND
OUR PROGRAM STRONGLY OPPOSES THE
PROPOSED CUTS FOR TO THE TAPE
PROGRAM. AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A
QUICK SENSE OF THE IMPACT, IT
WILL AT A MINIMUM, REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE BY 50. THAT MEANS AT
LEAST 10,000 HOURS WILL HAVE TO
BE CUT FROM OUR PROGRAM. AND TO
ANSWER AN EARLIER QUESTION THAT
CAME UP, WHAT IS THIS PROGRAM?
RETURN TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. EVERY YEAR, THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SBDCS
CONDUCTS A THIRD PARTY OBJECTIVE
REVIEW OF THE PROGRAM FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. EVERY
DOLLAR INVESTED RETURNS DIRECTLY
TO THE TREASURY. ABOUT $1.50,
AND THE MULTIPLIER IMPACT TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IS ABOUT $4
FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT THE STATE.
THANK YOU. WE AGAIN STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE CUTS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, DAVID NELSON,
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCACY COUNCIL HERE
WITH THE CREW TODAY AND OPPOSING
THIS CUT. AND AS YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR THEIR STORIES ABOUT HOW
THIS CUT WILL, IT IT'S REALLY AN
INEQUITABLE CUT BECAUSE AS A 50%
CUT ACROSS THE BOARD WILL SHRINK
SERVICES AND THOSE WHO ARE
HARDEST TO REACH AND HARDEST TO
SERVE WILL BE HIT THE MOST, I
APPRECIATE, KURT'S COMMENT ON
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE, BUT I DID WANT TO
POINT OUT A COUPLE OTHER
HIGHLIGHTED FACTS IN SENATOR
PADILLA'S DISTRICT LAST YEAR
ALONE, THE SBDC 1453 OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WERE SERVED SENATOR
NEAL, 3887 CONSTITUENTS AND
SENATOR SMALL WAS JUST LAST
YEAR, 3126. THAT'S JUST IN THE
SBDC NETWORK. AND, MORE DETAIL.
PARTS OF THOSE STATISTICS ARE
AVAILABLE THROUGH GO-BIZ AND THE
OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. WE OPPOSE THIS CUT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
CLAUDIA VÆ AND I'M REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTER NETWORK, WHICH IS NOW 21
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS AND
JUST RECENTLY ACQUIRED THREE ONE
IN SENATORS LOLA SMALLWOOD,
CUEVAS'S DISTRICT. WE'RE GLAD TO
SAY I WANTED TO, I JUST WANT TO
BE BLUNT. WE ARE REALLY SHOOTING
OURSELVES IN THE FOOT WITH THIS
TINY CUT, WHICH LEVERAGES AT
LEAST ANOTHER 30, $35 MILLION.
AND I THINK OTHER PEOPLE MADE
THE POINT OF WHAT THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IS. BUT I WANT TO
POINT OUT HOW IT AFFECTS WOMEN
IN PARTICULAR, BECAUSE IT WAS
WOMEN WHOSE BUSINESSES GOT US
OUT OF THE WHO HELPED US RECOVER
FROM THE PANDEMIC. SO LET'S LOOK
AT WHAT THE IMPACT WOULD BE OF
THIS CUT, WE HAD 12,000
BUSINESSES THAT WE STARTED AND
GREW LAST YEAR, AND THEY CREATED
386 MILLION IN REVENUES THIS IS
13 MILLION CUT, WHICH IS NOT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE VERY MUCH IS
GOING TO EVISCERATE THIS PROGRAM
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I ALREADY
ONE MINUTE. YES, MA'AM. OKAY.
GOES QUICKLY GUYS. YOU GOT A
QUICKER THAN WE ALL LIKE THE
MAIN POINT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS OSCAR
GARCIA. I'M THE SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
ON BEHALF OF THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WE ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE RECONSIDER
CUTTING THE FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. I'D LIKE TO ADD THAT
THE SBDC NETWORK WERE THE FIRST
RESPONDENTS. WHEN THE PANDEMIC
HIT, WE WERE THE ONES PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE, TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE, EDUCATION AND
GUIDANCE TO THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE LOST
THEIR BUSINESS. SO THOSE
FAMILIES WERE DISPLACED. IN
TURN, WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HELP
THEM THRIVE. WE REBUILD THEIR
BUSINESS, CREATE JOBS, STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY, AND THANKS TO THEM,
I MEAN A LOT OF MINORITIES,
HISPANICS, AFRICAN AMERICANS,
ASIAN NATIVE AMERICANS, THEY'RE
ABLE TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES,
THEY'RE ABLE TO THRIVE. AND THEY
ALSO CREATE JOBS AND CONTRIBUTE
TO THE COMMUNITY. AND NOT ONLY
IN YOUR COMMUNITY, REGIONALLY
AND STATEWIDE. SO I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE RECONSIDER THAT AND KEEP
US THE FUNDING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. BRILLIANT. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS RAY TATAR.
I'M LONG RETIRED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL FROM ITS
INCEPTION, WHERE I WORKED FOR 25
YEARS OF THE ORGANIZATIONAL
GRANTS PROGRAM, EXCUSE ME, I'M
SHOCKED BY THIS PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE ITS FUNDS DURING THE
PANDEMIC, MANY ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED. YOU WON'T SEE THE
SACRAMENTO THEATER COMPANY
ANYMORE. A HALF CENTURY OF
SERVING THE COMMUNITY WITH
BRILLIANT PLAYS, YOUTH EDUCATION
PROGRAMS CLOSED YESTERDAY. I'M
TELLING YOU, THESE CUTS ARE
PROPOSED, AT A TIME WHEN SUPPORT
FUNDING IS NEEDED MOST. MOST
LOCAL AUDIENCES ARE BEGINNING TO
RETURN. THERE'S A NEW CROP OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED TO BE
PART OF THE ARTS, TO WORK IN THE
ARTS AND ENJOY THEM. PEOPLE FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD ARE STARTING
TO VISIT CALIFORNIA AGAIN, AND I
BELIEVE THAT THEY THEY DESERVE
TO SEE THEATER, DANCE,
LITERATURE, MUSEUMS AND ARTS AND
ARTS EDUCATION. THANK YOU. I
THINK YOU GET THE PICTURE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR. VICE CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
TERRENCE SHEPHERD, SENIOR. I'M A
U.S. ARMY VETERAN. I'M A
BUSINESS CONSULTANT. AND WITH
THE NORCAL VETERAN BUSINESS
OUTREACH CENTER, THE VIDAK
MISSION IS TO SUPPORT VETERAN
TRANSITION MEMBERS AND MILITARY
SPOUSES THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
STARTING AND GROWING THEIR
BUSINESS OUT OF THE 28 VÆ BOX IN
THE UNITED STATES, CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY HAVE THREE. SO WE HAVE
THE NORCAL. WE HAVE THE SOCAL,
AND WE HAVE THE LOS ANGELES
REGIONAL. YOU KNOW, VIDAK AND WE
ALL SERVICE ALL 58 COUNTIES AND
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF THE
VIDAK, WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
GOVERNMENT, PROPOSED 50% CUT TO
THE SMALL BUSINESS TAX, YOU
KNOW, RESOURCE PROGRAM. A 50%
REDUCTION IN FUNDING COULD
RESULT IN A LOSS OF OVER 75% IN
SUPPORT SERVICES TO THE VETERAN
COMMUNITY AND INCREASE THE
VETERAN HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE URGE YOU TO
PRESERVE THE CORE SERVICES OF
TAP AND REJECT THE GOVERNMENT
PROPOSED CUTS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. HAVE A BLESSED DAY.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M JANICE FOSTER
DOWNS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, REPRESENTING THE MORE
THAN 754,000 AAPI OWNED
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE PROPOSED
CUTS FOR 50% OF THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THE ASIAN
CHAMBER MANAGES THE MINORITY
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT AGENCY FOR
SACRAMENTO, AS WELL AS THE US
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
SMALL BUSINESS TRANSPORTATION
RESOURCE CENTER, WHICH SERVES
OVER 2000 SMALL AND
DISADVANTAGED STATEWIDE
BUSINESSES, WHICH IN THE LAST
YEAR HAS RESULTED IN OVER 150
JOBS, CREATED MORE THAN 4000
JOBS RETURNED. EXCUSE ME,
RETAINED AND MORE THAN $35
MILLION OF INCREASED BUSINESS
CAPITAL. THE STATE'S REVENUE, AS
WELL AS YOUR DISTRICT'S, REALLY
RELY ON OUR CLIENTS SUCCESS,
WHICH WAS MENTIONED EARLIER. ONE
OF THE COMMENTS CUTTING 50% OF
THE THESE SERVICES REALLY CUTS
TO THE CORE OF PROVIDING SUPPORT
AND SERVICES TO SMALL AND
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESSES AND
WILL PARTICULARLY BE
DISPROPORTIONATE Kò, WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY HURT SMALL
AND MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES. WE HOPE YOU REJECT
THESE CUTS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS MARIA
VALENZUELA, I AM A C 45 LICENSED
CONTRACTOR. WE'VE BEEN IN THIS
TRADE FOR. WE BUILT OUR COMPANY.
SIGN COMPANY, AND WE'VE BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR 24 YEARS, WITH SBDC
, WE GETTING ALL THE
CERTIFICATIONS JUST RECENTLY,
HAS HELPED OUR BUSINESS OR MY
BUSINESS, TREMENDOUSLY. WE'RE
GETTING NOW BIDS EVERYWHERE. AND
I BELIEVE THAT OUR DREAM HAS IS
BECOMING TRUE, TO BE AT A
DIFFERENT LEVEL, TO DO MORE JOBS
FOR, EVERYTHING IS JUST, IT'S
JUST DIFFERENT FOR US. THIS IS
VERY, WONDERFUL WITH THIS
CERTIFICATIONS WITH THROUGH
SBDC. SO PLEASE RECONSIDER, NOT
CUTTING THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE IT
WILL HELP. IT'S HELPING MY
BUSINESS AND IT WILL HELP OTHER
BUSINESSES AS WELL THAT WE KNOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS DOMINGO, AND
, SOMEONE TOLD ME TO SPEAK IN
SPANISH BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO
SAY SOMETHING IN SPANISH, BUT I
DON'T KNOW. I DON'T SEE ANY WAY
WE WOULD NEED TO SPANISH HERE.
THEY DON'T HAVE A STAFF
TRANSLATOR AND I DON'T WANT TO
HAVE TO. MY GRAMMARS. LET ME
TRY. NOT THAT GOOD. LET ME TRY
AN ENGLISH. I CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES IN 1988. I'M A DREAMER.
AND EVERY TIME THERE'S A
CHALLENGE, I TRY TO CHANGE.
CHANGE TO THE BEST. WHEN I GOT
HIT BY COVID, LET'S SAY
EVERYBODY GOT HIT BY COVID, THE
BUSINESSES WENT DOWN. I HAD TO
THAT WAS A CHALLENGE. NOW I HAVE
30 EMPLOYEES, A VOLUME OF $3
MILLION. SEVEN OF THEM ARE
HOMELESS, BUT I'M TAKING CARE OF
THEM. SO NOW THEY GOT THEY CAME
BACK TO THE LIVING. IF YOU CUT
THIS VIDAK, THAT WAS, SBDC TO ME
WAS LIKE A THE DREAM THAT I WAS
GOING DOWN. TWO MONTHS AGO, I
MET SBDC THROUGH MY, MY DAUGHTER
CAME TO ME AND SAY, THIS IS
GOING TO GET YOU TO
CERTIFICATIONS. SO I DIDN'T
BELIEVE IT. I SAID, NO, NO, I'M
TOO BUSY TO GO TO SCHOOL, TOO
BUSY TO GO TO SCHOOL. AND MY
WIFE WENT TO SCHOOL. SO I GOT TO
SEE IT ON THE THIRD SATURDAY.
AND I WAS WHAT? HOW COME I
DIDN'T KNOW THIS 20 YEARS AGO?
EVERYBODY ALL THE SMALL
BUSINESSES NEED TO KNOW THIS.
SMALL BUSINESSES NEED TO BE
CERTIFIED SO THEY CAN OPEN THE
MARKET SO THEY CAN OPEN THE
MARKET EVERYWHERE, ALL THE WAY
TO ALL THE WAY TO THE GULF, ALL
THE WAY TO STATE, COUNTY,
CITIES, FEDERAL. THEY NEED IT.
NOBODY KNOWS THIS TO ME. I
DIDN'T KNOW YOU DID. WELL, THANK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE AND
YOUR PATIENCE. WELCOME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, GOOD AFTERNOON,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. MY NAME IS
ALEX MONTOYA. I'M A SERVICE,
DISABLED, VETERAN OWNED SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER, I ORIGINALLY
ASKED YOU GUYS RECONSIDER
CUTTING THE BUDGET BECAUSE NOT
ONLY ARE YOU SEVERING THE
BUDGET, BUT YOU'RE ALSO SEVERING
THE NETWORK AND THE
RELATIONSHIPS AND THE COMMUNITY
THAT WE HAVE BUILT AND I SEE IT
EVERY TIME I GO TO THESE
COMMUNITIES MEETINGS, THE
COHORTS AT THE LOCAL OFFICE OF
EDUCATION, IN STOCKTON,
CALIFORNIA, AND AS STATED IN THE
DISCUSSION ON THE ISSUE, WE IT
WILL HINDER US, AND IT WILL
LEAVE US VULNERABLE BECAUSE
WITHOUT THESE, THIS NETWORK,
THIS COMMUNITY THAT I BUILT, I
WOULDN'T BE IN THE POSITION I AM
TODAY HAVING THE OPPORTUNITIES I
AM TODAY. SO I URGENTLY ASK YOU
GUYS RECONSIDER THAT DECISION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI, HEIDI.
I DON'T NEED THIS. HEIDI PICKMAN
FROM THE CAMEO NETWORK, WHERE,
NETWORK OF 400 MISSION DRIVEN
ORGANIZATIONS MADE UP OF SMALL
BUSINESS, SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
PROVIDERS, AS WELL AS OTHER AS
WELL AS A LOT OF THE BUSINESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
HERE. WE DO NOT BENEFIT FROM
THIS PROGRAM. OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES DO AS YOU CAN. AS
YOU'VE HEARD, CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATOR WISELY INVESTED IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF SMALL
BUSINESS SUPPORT DURING DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. AND I CALL IT AN
INVESTMENT BECAUSE YOU ARE
GETTING A RETURN ON YOUR
INVESTMENT AS OTHERS HAVE
STATED, IF THIS INVESTMENT IS
CUT, THE DIVERSE ENTREPRENEURS
THAT SOME OF THEM WHO WE'VE MET
HERE WILL SUFFER THE MOST, I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT A
MCKINSEY REPORT. SAID THAT IF
BLACK ENTREPRENEURS WERE ON PAR
WITH THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS,
THAT WOULD ADD MORE THAN $1
TRILLION TO THE ECONOMY, AND
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THESE ARE
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
HELPING BRING THEM ON PAR. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR PADILLA, VICE
CHAIR. NILO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS SCOTT
ROGOWSKI. ON BEHALF OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS, COVERING 36
COUNTIES, MOST OF THEM RURAL,
AND THE 1000 BUSINESSES THAT WE
SERVE, 50% ARE WOMEN, 50 AND,
BIPOC OWNED, WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE 50% CUT TO SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
TAP IS A CORE SERVICE AND SAFETY
NET FOR SMALL BUSINESSES TO HELP
THEM LAUNCH, CREATE JOBS, ACCESS
MONEY TO BUILD CAPACITY WITHOUT
THE SBDC, TAP FUNDING, THESE
BUSINESSES WILL NOT GROW AND GET
ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES AND
GUIDANCE THEY NEED. WE URGE YOU
TO PRESERVE THE CORE SERVICES OF
SMALL BUSINESS. TAP AND REJECT
THE PROPOSED CUTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M MARIANNE
PETRILLO, CEO OF WEST CENTER IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE HOST A
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER AND AN
SBDC, AND WE ALSO LEAD THE BLUE
ECONOMY AND WORKING LAND SECTOR
TABLE FOR THE CALIFORNIA JOBS
FIRST INITIATIVE IN OUR REGION.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED CUTS.
FOR 36 YEARS, WEST CENTER HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING
THOUSANDS OF RURAL SMALL
BUSINESSES LAUNCH AND GROW. WHEN
THE PANDEMIC HIT, 30% OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES CLOSED IN A
COUNTY WHERE 98% OF THE ECONOMY
RELIES ON SMALL BUSINESSES IS
THE LOSS OF TAX REVENUE WAS
STAGGERING. TAP FUNDING HAS BEEN
CRUCIAL IN REBUILDING OUR TAX
BASE, IGNITING NEW ENTERPRISES
AND ALLOWING US TO CREATE
PROGRAMS LIKE CENTRAL LATINO
WEST, WHICH SERVES HUNDREDS OF
HISPANIC LATINO BUSINESSES
EXCLUSIVELY A 50% CUT IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES LIKE OURS WILL FEEL
MORE LIKE A 70% CUT DUE TO THE
LACK OF ALTERNATIVE SUPPORT
NETWORKS. JOBS WILL DISAPPEAR,
OUR TAX REVENUES WILL PLUNGE,
AND ALL OF THIS AT A CRUCIAL
TIME WHEN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IS
NOW POISED TO ADVANCE THE GROWTH
OF WIND ENERGY, INNOVATIVE OCEAN
AND AQUACULTURE RESEARCH,
BIOMASS AND HYDROGEN
TECHNOLOGIES. WE URGE YOU TO
RECONSIDER THESE CUTS AS THE
FUTURE OF OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND THE BROADER ECONOMIC
LANDSCAPE OF CALIFORNIA DEPENDS
ON IT. THANK YOU. HEY THERE.
THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN, VICE
CHAIRMAN, MY NAME IS BIANCA
BLOMQUIST. I'M THE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA NHÀ FOR SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY, FOR A
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY AND
EDUCATIONAL ORGANIZATION. WE
REPRESENT ALMOST 100,000 SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. THE AVERAGE
SIZE OF A BUSINESS IN OUR
NETWORK HAS FOUR EMPLOYEES. AND
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THESE ARE THE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE LEAST LIKELY
TO HAVE A DEDICATED HR
DEPARTMENT TO HAVE ACCESS TO
SOPHISTICATED, SOPHISTICATED
LEGAL RESOURCES AND TO ACCESS
THE TYPES OF BUSINESS PLANNING
AND SUPPORT SERVICES THAT THE
SBDCS WOMEN BUSINESS CENTERS,
APEX ACCELERATORS AND VBOX
PROVIDE. THE 50% CUT TO TAP
WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY, DISASTROUS
FOR SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND COULD NOT COME AT
A WORSE TIME. WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOU, REJECTING THIS
CUT. THANK YOU. HELLO,
EVERYBODY. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS SOFIA CANNON, AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTER. HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND I AM HERE TO ASK
YOU ALL TO PLEASE RECONSIDER
YOUR DECISION TO CUT THE TAP
FUNDING BY 50. WE IN SACRAMENTO
ARE WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER
ALONE SERVE OVER A THOUSAND
BUSINESSES EACH YEAR THROUGH
ONGOING COUNSELING AND TRAINING.
BUT ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS WE HAVE HAD WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CREATE A LICENSE TO CARE
CHILD CARE TRAINING PROGRAM. AS
WE ALL KNOW, AFTER THE PANDEMIC,
CHILD CARE AS A WHOLE WAS REALLY
JUST NON-EXISTENT, WHERE WE SAW
AN IMMENSE AMOUNT OF CHILD CARE
DESERTS AND US AS THE WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS. AND NOT ONLY
MY OWN HERE, BUT WE HAVE 11
OTHER WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, A Ã THERE'S 21 OR
21, BUT 11 OF US HAVE CREATED
CHILD CARE TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT
THROUGH THIS TAP FUNDING AND NOT
ONLY THROUGH WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTERS. ARE WE TRYING TO SERVE
WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES AS A WHOLE. BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO GIVE BACK TO THE
ECONOMY. WE WANT THE ECONOMY TO
GROW. SO BY GIVING WOMEN, WOMEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE CHILD
CARE BUSINESSES, YOU THEN GIVE
FAMILIES THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE AND TO
BUILD THAT WORKFORCE. AND SO I
AM HERE AGAIN TO ASK YOU ALL TO
PLEASE RECONSIDER YOUR DECISION
TO CUT TAP FUNDING. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, PREET
AHLUWALIA, ON BEHALF OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SBDC, WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
50% CUT TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THIS CUT COULD LEAD TO 7,575%
REDUCTION IN SERVICES FOR MOST
UNDERSERVED AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES, AND IN SOME CASES,
STOP SERVICES COMPLETELY STAND
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES. IF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JULIE BAKER, CEO, CEO,
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING OVER 15,000 ARTS
AND CULTURE NONPROFITS IN
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSITION TO THE
DISPROPORTIONATE CUTS TO ARTS
FUNDING IN TOTAL, 58% OF PROGRAM
FUNDS, INCLUDING $10 MILLION IN
GRANTS FUNDING TO THE ARTS
COUNCIL, AND THE $12.5 MILLION
THE EQUITABLE PAYROLL FUND
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE, WHICH
IS NOT A NEW PROGRAM, REALLY.
IT'S REPURPOSED FUNDS FROM THE
LIVE VENUES AND NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS GRANTS PROGRAM.
AND AS SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS'S QUESTION TO THE
BENEFITS OF THE PERFORMING ARTS
FOR 100 EVERY 100 JOBS IN THE
PERFORMING ARTS, THERE ARE 156
DOWNSTREAM BENEFITS, NOT TO
MENTION SIGNIFICANT TAX
REVENUES. 10 MILLION CUT TO CÁC
CÁC FUNDING BELOW THE 1989 90
FUNDING LEVEL WITHOUT ADJUSTING
FOR INFLATION. WHILE THE GENERAL
FUND IS MORE THAN DOUBLED, CÁC
IS ALREADY IN A CUT POSITION AND
SHOULD BE SPARED. SHOULD THESE
CUTS GO THROUGH. I JUST WANT
MEMBERS TO UNDERSTAND THIS WOULD
PUT CÁC 45TH, PUT CALIFORNIA
45TH IN THE UNITED STATES FOR
FUNDING FOR THE ARTS, WOULD PUT
US BEHIND ALABAMA AND FLORIDA,
FLORIDA. CURRENTLY, CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS 25% OF THE UNITED
STATES CREATIVE ECONOMY. IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE, ARTS AND
CULTURE REPRESENTS 8% OF THE
STATE'S GDP. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OPPOSE THE CUTS. THANKS JANICE
NORMAN, ON BEHALF OF CAL
BROADBAND HERE ON ISSUE 23, THE
MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND INITIATIVE
WOULD ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE LAO
AND REJECTING THE PROPOSED
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO THE
POINT EARLIER, YOU MAY HAVE
RECEIVED INFORMATION, BUT YOU
HAVE YET TO RECEIVE ANSWERS
UNTIL THE LEGISLATURE RECEIVES
ACTUAL ANSWERS ABOUT THOSE
INVESTMENTS, UNILATERAL
AUTHORITY DOESN'T MAKE MUCH
SENSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
EDUARDO MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF ACTORS EQUITY, WE'RE A
NATIONAL UNION OF 51,000
MEMBERS, IN THE LIVE ARTS. AND
WE'RE HERE TO SPEAK AGAINST THE
$10 MILLION CUT TO THE ARTS
COUNCIL, AS WELL AS THE 12.5
MILLION FOR THE PERFORMING ARTS
EQUITABLE PAYROLL FUND. WE WERE
ONE OF THE CHIEF SPONSORS OF THE
EQUITABLE PAYROLL FUND, WHICH IS
REALLY MEANT TO FUND WORKERS IN
THE LIVE ARTS, NOT BUILDINGS,
NOT LOBBIES, BUT WORKERS, REALLY
WANT TO JUST PIGGYBACK ON THE
COMMENT FROM SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS THAT THE INVESTMENTS IN
THE ARTS HAVE A RIPPLE EFFECT ON
OUR ECONOMY. WE KNOW THAT WE'VE
DONE STUDIES. WE'VE DONE THE
WORK, WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO REJECT THIS CUT, WHICH,
AGAIN, WOULD MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED WOULD BRING US BACK TO
FUNDING LEVELS GOING BACK TO
1989. THE ARTS ARE A REALLY
IMPORTANT, PUBLIC BENEFIT, AND
IT'S PUBLIC FUNDING IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT ARTS AND CULTURAL
EXPERIENCES ARE, ARE SERVED, ARE
PROVIDED TO IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND SUPPORTING
CREATIVE CAREERS. SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS. THANK YOU.
I'M SHORT. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR.
THE VICE CHAIR, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE, FOR THIS GREAT
STATE, I WHAT YOU'RE DOING HAS
GOT TO BE VERY DIFFICULT. MY
NAME IS LES FONG. I'M DIRECTOR
OF THE SBDC FOR SAN JOAQUIN.
AMADOR CALAVERAS AND ALPINE
COUNTIES, RURAL COUNTIES AND THE
PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS WILL
DRAMATICALLY IMPACT, THE AMOUNT
OF SERVICE THAT I CAN GIVE TO
THE RURAL COUNTIES, AND THERE'S
A TREMENDOUS RETURN ON YOUR
INVESTMENT BY INVESTING IN US
AND A PRIME EXAMPLE IS JUST ONE
OF THE PROGRAMS IS A
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. IN THE
LAST THREE MONTHS, WE GOT 44
SMALL BUSINESSES CERTIFIED AS
EITHER, SMALL MINORITY WOMEN
OWNED, VETERAN OWNED BUSINESSES.
AND OF THOSE, WE ACTUALLY HAVE
THREE OF THEM THAT ACTUALLY GOT
CONTRACTS ALL WITHIN A THREE
MONTH PERIOD. SO CAN YOU IMAGINE
WHAT WE DO, WHAT WE CAN DO BY
BEING ABLE TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM? SO I IMPLORE YOU,
PLEASE DON'T CUT OUR SERVICES.
AND ESPECIALLY IN OUR RURAL
COUNTY, WE'RE TREMENDOUSLY
IMPACTED. THANK YOU. HELLO, I'M
DEBORAH DUBON FROM DEBORAH DUBON
CONSULTING. I WAS A VETERAN
TRYING TO FIND A JOB WHEN I
STARTED MY FIRST BUSINESS, AND I
NEEDED SOME HELP. I DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO GET THINGS STARTED AND
HOW TO BEGIN TO GROW. AND NOW I
GET TO PROVIDE THOSE KIND THAT
KIND OF HELP TO A WHOLE ARRAY OF
CLIENTS. AS ONE OF THE
CONSULTANTS AT THE SBDC. SO I
SEE ON A DAILY BASIS WHAT IT
MEANS FOR PEOPLE FROM LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TO GET THAT HELP
BUSINESS IS MANY OF OUR AMERICAN
DREAM AND WE NEED THAT LITTLE
BIT OF HELP THAT THE TAP PROGRAM
CAN PROVIDE. SO PLEASE DON'T CUT
THAT FUNDING. THANK YOU. HI. MY
NAME IS SHIRA LANE. I'M WITH
ATRIUM 916 WHERE A CREATIVE
INNOVATION CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABILITY. I'M HERE BECAUSE
OUR ARTISTS CREATE PRODUCTS LIKE
THIS WHICH IS MADE OUT OF
INNERTUBE TIRES. WE HAVE AN
INCUBATOR AND NOW WE HAVE AN
ACCELERATOR. BUT NONE OF THIS
WOULD HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT
THE CALIFORNIANS FOR THE ARTS.
THEY SAW THE POTENTIAL IN WHAT
WE WERE DOING AND HOW WE WERE
INNOVATING AND HELPING OUR LOCAL
CREATIVES BUILD SUSTAINABLE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE TRADABLE
PRODUCTS. NOW WE HAVE AN
ACCELERATOR, AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE ARTS
COUNCIL FOR SEEING THE POTENTIAL
IN WHAT WE WERE DOING WHEN
REGULAR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS DID NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE WERE DOING. THE ARTS ARE
CRITICAL AND WE SEE A
DISPROPORTIONATE,
DISPROPORTIONATE CUT TOWARDS THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL. AND WE
PLEASE, PLEASE CONSIDER
CALIFORNIANS FOR THE ARTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
, VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS SWAHILI
ALEX. I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
SACRAMENTO VALLEY SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER SBDC. MY
PROGRAM SERVES FOUR COUNTIES
SACRAMENTO, YOLO, YUBA, AND
SUTTER. AND AS YOU MAY KNOW,
THREE OF MY COUNTIES 90, 95% OF
THE THREE COUNTIES THAT I SERVE
IS STILL CONSIDERED RURAL
THROUGH THE TAP FUNDING, WE'RE
ABLE TO HOST OFFICE HOURS IN THE
INDIVIDUAL IN THE RESPECTIVE
COUNTIES THAT WE SERVE. AND ALSO
WE'RE ABLE TO BRING ABOUT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
BUSINESS TRAINING THAT IS SO
BADLY NEEDED IN THESE THREE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
FELT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
SIDELINED, AND NOT TO MENTION
THAT THE TAP FUNDING IS
INSTRUMENTAL IN ENABLING US TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
THE REFUGEES, TO THE ASYLEES WHO
DON'T HAVE AN IDENTITY YET IN
THIS COUNTRY. BUT WE'RE ABLE TO
SERVE THEM WITH ENTREPRENEURSHIP
TRAINING AND ONE ON ONE ADVISING
THROUGH TAP FUNDING. SO I
IMPLORE YOU TO NOT CUT THE
FUNDING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS DARBY
KERNAN, REPRESENTING GRACE TO
END CHILD POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE HERE TO OPPOSE, ISSUE 21,
THE, THE CAL KIDS FINANCIAL
LITERACY OUTREACH. WE ASK YOU TO
REJECT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PROPOSAL, BUT EVEN MORE SO, THE
LÀ ORTEZ PROPOSAL, WHICH
RECOMMENDS TAKING MORE FUNDING.
THOSE DOLLARS ARE USED TO PRINT
FORMS AND PROVIDE THINGS IN
VARIOUS LANGUAGES SO THAT WE CAN
KIND OF BREAK THE GAP OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE GETTING IN, ACCESSING
THE CAL KIDS TO OTHER AREAS. SO
IF NOTHING ELSE, YOU'VE HEARD,
THEY HAVE SOMEBODY HIRED, THEY
CAN CONTINUE THIS WORK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI. THANK YOU
FOR INVITING US TO SPEAK. A I
HAVE A SPEECH, PROBLEM, CLEARLY.
SO PLEASE BEAR WITH ME. MY NAME
IS AMANDA SANCHEZ, AND I AM HERE
TO OPPOSE ISSUE 26, THE $10
MILLION BUDGET CUT TO THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AS THE
CO-DIRECTOR OF CAPITAL CREATIVE
ALLIANCE, A SMALL ARTS NONPROFIT
THAT SUPPORTS CREATIVE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE SACRAMENTO
REGION, WE RELY ON THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL TO
SUPPORT OUR PROGRAMING AND TO
PAY OUR STAFF,
I'M GOING TO GO. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE DOING FINE, MISS SANCHEZ.
TAKE THE TIME YOU NEED. THANK
YOU. HI NICOLE WATERMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN OPPOSITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
FUNDING FOR THE MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND INITIATIVE, AS WELL AS
BROADBAND FOR ALL INITIATIVE.
I'VE, BROADBAND IS A SOCIAL
DETERMINANT OF HEALTH FOR
CHILDREN, AND IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT EVERYONE BE ABLE
TO BE CONNECTED. THANK YOU, MISS
SANCHEZ. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY, I'LL GIVE YOU THE TIME
YOU NEED. MA'AM ADDITIONALLY, IF
YOU WANTED TO FINISH YOUR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT, I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE WELCOME YOU AND
YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU'RE WELCOME. NEXT
HELLO, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS,
STEPHANIE ROBERSON, REPRESENTING
THE BAY AREA REGIONAL HEALTH
INEQUITIES INITIATIVE, OR BAR.
HI, I'M SPEAKING ON ITEM, NOT ON
THE AGENDA. SO I APPRECIATE, YOU
AND SENATOR WIENER FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ON AN ITEM, NOT ON
THE AGENDA. SO I'LL TALK REAL
FAST. OKAY, SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD THIS REQUEST BEFORE, IT
WAS A TOP AGENDA ITEM WITH THE
BAY AREA CAUCUS, SOME YEARS AGO,
AS A BUDGET PRIORITY. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORI WILSON,
CHAIR OF THE BLACK CAUCUS.
CARRIED IT A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, WITH A FEW TWEAKS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT LEVEL FOLKS,
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, BUDGET
ISSUES, AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP, I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE COMING TOGETHER TO KIND
OF STRATEGIZE AROUND THE ISSUE
OF BLACK DISPLACEMENT, SO ON
BEHALF OF THE BLACK HOUSING
ADVISORY TASK FORCE OR BLACK
HAT, WE ARE REQUESTING STATE
INVESTMENT FROM EXISTING
RESOURCES THAT COULD BE FROM THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES GRANT
PROGRAM OR THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE FUND, ADMINISTERED BY
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL, TO
ESTABLISH A BLACK HOUSING
RESILIENCE FUND THAT FOCUSES ON
ABOUT 15 AND GROWING CITIES
STATEWIDE. THERE'S BEEN
INTENSIVE FOCUS ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE CITIES,
BACKED BY DATA AND REFERENCED IN
THE URBAN INSTITUTE REPORT ON
CHANGING LANDSCAPES, AND ALSO
INTENSIVE, LOCALIZED BUY IN FROM
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF WORK ON HELPING CREATE
A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN STATE
PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS, AND YOU
ALL TO STOP THIS VIRTUAL CYCLE
OF DISPLACEMENT WITH BLACK
CALIFORNIANS. SO WE ENVISION
THIS FUND TO CREATE A VIRTUAL
CYCLE OF DEVELOPMENT TO IMPROVE
THE HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
WELL-BEING OF BLACK CALIFORNIANS
, WHICH AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THAT SUPPORTS ALL OF CALIFORNIA,
BECAUSE WE ARE ONE CALIFORNIA
AND WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
COMMUNITY PLANNING SO WE CAN
START TO ENVISION A FUTURE
PROJECTS, ESPECIALLY IN PARTS OF
REGIONS THAT THERE, IS A GROWTH
OF, A BURGEONING BLACK
POPULATION, SO AT THE END OF
THAT, WE WANT TO REALLY STRESS
THAT THERE'S BEEN NO STATE
STRATEGY, UP TO THIS POINT, FOR
THE CYCLE OF EXCLUSION,
DISPLACEMENT DISPLACED AND
DISINVESTMENT IN THESE
COMMUNITIES. AND WE HOPE THAT WE
CAN PARTNER WITH YOU ALL, AT THE
TAIL END OF THIS, TO FOCUS ON A
COMMUNITY PLANNING, BRICK AND
MORTAR PROJECTS, TO REALIZE A
THRIVING, HEALTHY, RESILIENT
COMMUNITY FOR ALL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. HOPE TO WORK WITH YOU IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE. THANK YOU. TONY
SIMONS. AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN INDIAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE OF
CALIFORNIA. THEY RUN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN APEX, HERE WE ARE HERE
TO OPPOSE THE $30 MILLION CUT
FOR THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM, I THINK, AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
TESTIFIED THAT TAP HAS A VERY
UNIQUE NETWORK OF ACTUALLY
REACHING ALL 58 STATES AND
HAVING PARTNERS THAT HAVE UNIQUE
RELATIONSHIPS. THEY'RE TRUSTED
PARTNERS WITHIN POPULATIONS THAT
ARE HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN
INCLUDED. AND WHEN THE STATE OR
ANYONE ELSE IS SERVING SMALL
BUSINESSES IN OUR CASE, THE APEX
ACCELERATOR FOR NATIVE
AMERICANS, YOU SAW WE HAVE A
HISPANIC CHAMBER. THERE ARE
HISPANIC SBDCS AND ACROSS THE
BOARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
THANKS TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED AND PROVIDED YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE ITEMS
FOR VOTE ONLY ON THE DOCKET.
THIS IS COMPRISED OF ISSUES ONE
THROUGH EIGHT RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR ALL ISSUE ITEMS ARE APPROVED
AS BUDGETED. WE WILL TAKE THESE
ITEMS IN TWO GROUPS. FIRST,
STARTING WITH ISSUES NUMBER ONE
AND THREE. RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE AS BUDGETED. I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SO MOVED
MOVED BY SENATOR NILO TO APPROVE
AS BUDGETED BY SENATOR NILO. I
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS THANK
YOU. THE AYES ARE THREE. THE
NO'S ARE ZERO, AND THOSE ITEMS
ARE OUT. SECONDARILY, WE WILL
MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND
ISSUES FOUR THROUGH EIGHT.
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE AS
BUDGETED. I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. MOVE BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
RECOMMENDATIONS. APPROVE AS
BUDGETED CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR PADILLA. AYE.
SENATOR NILO NØ. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD, THANK YOU. THE AYES
ARE TWO. THE NO'S ARE ONE. THOSE
ITEMS ARE OUT. THANKS EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THOSE THAT
DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE INPUT TO THE SUB CAN DO
SO DIRECTLY TO THE STAFF AND THE
WEBSITE. THANK YOU ALL VERY,
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK TODAY.
AT THIS TIME. SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER FOUR STANDS ADJOURNED